all right we're going to get started
here um I would like representative
Kenny to please lead us in this pledge
of
allegiance alce to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
all thank you and good
morning welcome to environment and
agriculture everybody I know we have uh
several people who are out today uh
representative verville um kraton's out
uh Bosman and ger is out um so but we we
can have
and Alison representative nav won't be
till later this afternoon I'm don't know
about representative brard I think he
might be out today too but um for the
folks who are here um we are going to
have a work session and talk about the
bills that we heard yesterday and see
where um what's everybody's thoughts
about uh what we heard and we'll start
with HB
1351 prohibiting the sale and use of
adhesive based rodent traps I make a
suggestion would you uh yes could we
start with uh the Kangaroos and then go
to the abuse registry and and then end
with the traps sure I think the the Fue
traps is going to be the longest
discussion by far so
okay make it so we'll make it so so then
let's start with uh HB
1325 relative to allowing private
ownership of small-tailed monkeys
kangaroos um who would like to start off
the conversation on that uh very
interesting Bill representative
Howard I very much thank you madam chair
I very much want to start this off
because I feel that it was a f it's a
frivolous Bill and um and I and I'm a
little bit um
disturbed by the the amount of time that
we put into it um so I I you know I
would um I would move to itl or whatever
it takes to get rid of this
bill well we can't itl today because
it's not
noticed um but I believe the the first
opportunity that we have to itl this
bill we will grab it I'm sure
representative
Duty I totally Concur and and I really
really think we need to be talking to
leadership about triaging some of these
bills like this um I do like the use of
the word frivolous because I think that
really explains what we're dealing with
here and if we allow the process to take
over and continue to um give these bills
the consideration that we did yesterday
I think we're just going to encourage
encourage them I so I think we need to
address this at some
level
okay representative
Kenny yes thank you I just think that it
leaves so many questions how are people
going to get otter and skunks and
raccoons are they going to go out and
try and trap them themselves there's
just so many and the vaccines the whole
thing there was just so much left
unanswered and I I just um
don't don't like a bill like this when
it it's not complete and I do think it's
frivolous representative um Bixby sorry
yeah so um when I asked about whether
there was a difference between
a inanimate object and a pet and the
answer was no that pretty much sealed it
from me because we have an entire
section of law on animal cruelty that is
based on the idea that animals are not
just property there they are there's
there's more responsibility for to for
an animal than there is for uh inanimate
property and uh and yes animals are
property but they are not only property
and uh and anytime that you acquire a
pet you are acquiring a set of
responsibilities that is beyond just
proper property and uh when if if these
if someone decide discovers that they
can no longer take care of a kangaroo or
a short-tailed monkey does that then go
to a shelter and do the shelters have
any capacity for dealing with that uh if
there is a complaint about uh animal
neglect because people aren't taking
care of the Kangaroos and their monkeys
is what are what is going what are our
local who he's going to do with
that representative ktoa thank you I
can't keep
anymore thank you madam chair we won't
talk we won't talk anymore about the
joies um but anyways
um the bigger question for me was it was
going to they were going to be companion
animals um and that
just is an area of law that these
animals should not be part
of um and I think just having it in that
section
questionable I concur with everything
that's been said that you know one of
the things too is that you know if if
somebody wants to have such a a deep
desire to have monkeys or raccoons or
foxes I mean if they want to open up um
they can still own them here in New
Hampshire you can get a special
certificate if you want to open up a zoo
or you want to have a a private zoo or
if you want to have a um an uh Wildlife
Education Center or something like that
um there's no reason why you couldn't
have that
but I know we're going to be hearing
another kangaroo Bill having to do with
kangaroo Farm farming kangaroo uh
Slaughter that kind of thing so um in
that sense I guess when we get to that
bill we're also going to have to look at
the issue of owning a kangaroo in New
Hampshire um but I guess that's going to
be for that bill when we hear that um
but for me yeah I the more people that I
talked to about um these particular this
particular list of animals and even if
we crossed some animals off and said
some were good and some were not good um
I just feel
like um these are these are really
animals that are not meant to be
domesticated they C they probably cannot
be
domesticated um they are they present
problems for the owners for um family
members that may be around them um I've
heard some horrendous stories about uh
people in other states who have owned
monkeys who have been um disfigured from
them they are not the these just these
are not animals that are meant to be in
homes uh
and it's also not in talking to some
veterinarians it's also not to the
animals benefit to be kept in a home
environment um because it's not their
natural habitat they can't Thrive and
and grow well um in that in that sense
so for me this is an absolute itl for
this bill but any other comments my
represent comment is that I agree and I
don't think we should spend any more
time on it yes let's move
on hp55 establishing an animal abuse
offender
registry uh any
comments or concerns about that
representative
Duty um I I think this bill should be
ited because I don't from our
questioning I don't think that it meets
the intent of what the sponsor wanted
but at the same time I really think the
committee needs to be looking at
tightening or how we go about um
supporting our Animal Control Officers
uh with some of these abuse
um complaints that that they see I mean
we've seen this over and over again
where shelter employees um Animal
Control Officers uh people that work at
the Department of Agriculture are really
traumatized by what they see out there
and the fact that they don't feel that
law enforcement or the Judiciary System
can back them up so I think at some
point we need to look at that and maybe
we think about something like an animal
Court
so that you have a judge that's trained
in these kinds of
things yeah represent
kto thank you madam chair um I agree
with you that what the you know the bill
is trying to do does not meet that
although last year or I think it was
last year representative Bixby could
correct me um I introduced a bill to may
have an ACO as part of the sheriff's
department in each County
um and they would be responsible for
knowing any that goes on in each County
which I think would meet would have met
what we're trying to do here um that was
met with a lot of resistance from acos
themselves and the police um because
they felt like they're they would be
overstepped um that was not the intent
um but because the sheriff has a a
greater deal of uh law enforcement where
they can issue warrants immediately and
do things it would have helped um solve
some um get animals that are being
abused out of those uh areas almost
immediately um so um I think that
something on a regional basis is is how
we would need to look at this
representative Bixby yeah so um I think
that um um I I agree with Barbara I
think that the the her bill from last
time last time it wasn't wasn't quite in
wasn't quite ready for prime time um and
that you know I was a co-sponsor on it
so I bear some of the responsibility
there too but but uh one of the things
that I think is important with that is
that this is not the purview of our
committee this is a criminal justice
issue and if we want to move in that
direction we need to coordinate with
criminal justice uh uh and I think that
uh in terms of this the bill we've heard
here I think there are all sorts of dup
process implications that we don't have
the expertise to assess and but they
they concern me uh and I I think that
um uh I guess our our friends from CSG
are not here at the moment but they were
in on the discussion a number of years
ago about a very similar Bill and
uh we came to the conclusion at that
point that it was inexpedient to
legislate and I don't see anything in
this bill that has improved
that I concur with uh all that's been
um you know aside from the the you know
making lists and that people can become
Target if targets if they're on the list
and and all of
that I do think that you know the
um a good point was brought up in that
there needs to be some better
communication within law enforcement as
to who's been arrested for what or who's
been indicted for what or who's been
charged or uh convicted of for what
crimes so that there's you know
some um some knowledge of what they may
need to have um an awareness of um so I
I like you your idea um
yeah and uh I I do believe uh absolutely
this is this is more of a criminal
justice and and law enforcement
communication issue than it is for you
know us to say we should have some sort
of registry of people representative
Murray and then uh comto thank you madam
chair I also think that there might be
other questions with regard to the
judicial process and Judiciary so I did
want to make sure that to representative
bixby's point that whether it's criminal
justice or Judiciary that those facets
are far beyond sort of our scope and
outside of that and I I you know in in
the investigative process or whatever
due process things are happening in the
scope of an investigation I think that
those are also things that would need to
be considered different you know okay
represent com thank you and just because
you brought up you know the stalking and
the internet stuff
the idea behind a county um places they
would keep the records it would be held
in confidence but law enforcement would
have access to it not the general public
important all right
then um so I think we're pretty um
pretty United in the thought that this
this bill um would be an
itl all right um moving along to uh the
last that we heard yesterday of uh HB
1351 prohibiting the sale and use of
adhesive based rodent traps who would
like to start the conversation on that
representative Howard thank you madam
chair um I I was uh I mean I I think
that the the issue of Cruelty is should
not go unrecognized or un un but um I
also just like the last time we talked
about when we talked about the Andy
coagulate um the professional it was
very persuasive the young man who who
does it for a living and and in the
hands of professionals I I don't think
that the cruelty goes away but but it we
recognize the um the need for it
more
Yep anyone else I I have reached out to
New Hampshire Farm Bureau to ask that
they weigh in on this um bill as well
and I'm waiting to hear back from um Rob
Johnson but uh just in initial
conversation prior to our meeting this
morning um he said that um you know
there are some Farmers that do make use
of uh of the glue traps
um and that you know it's another tool
to be used um a lot of
these uh tools that we use to control or
eliminate the rodent population they're
they're not um they're not wonderful
tools for the rodent but it's designed
not to be uh um a good thing for the
rodents because we want to get rid of
them for a number of different reasons
in any case representative comto thank
you madam chair
and I I do have I brought in a couple
different samples um and I can pass them
around this one here it talks about
please to mainly euthanize the mouse
before disposing of the Trap and it says
do not Place trap where birds or
non-target animals may come into contact
it's very specific on here and the thing
is is most in agriculture I would say
that
um we they're used like in the barns uh
individuals use them in their homes but
they use them instead of bait because
they're afraid that their other animals
if they got into them would ingest the
poison um and so although this may not
be I don't I I don't know if there's any
humane way of really killing anything um
just going to throw that out there um
but these are a health
hazard um in agriculture and in our
homes um what are the the mice are
health hazard or the glue traps the the
rodents okay well the rodents are the
health hazard um because you know their
feces are a problem um they're very
destructive
um and they multiply
rapidly um so there's this one here like
I said and it talk about uh how to
humanely dispose of it I mean it doesn't
tell you how to do it it just asks that
you do it humanely and it does say do
not come in contact with other things um
this one here is uh for rat mouse and
snake um I would never use it for a
snake because um snakes eat mice snakes
eat mice so and uh I don't have any
snakes in my house to the best of I my
ability but tells you where to put them
it says on floors under sinks and along
baseboards doesn't say to use outside in
the garden or anything like that because
as we heard from the professional who
testified yesterday if they get dust or
dirt on them if they're out for two or
three days the adhesive no longer works
so they're useless so I think when we're
talking the person was talking about
gardening and things like that it's like
in either potting shed or a barn or even
in your home but you have to give people
some tools to utilize I mean there's all
kinds of tools but even catching
something in a trap if you don't catch
it is going to Res you know is not going
to be Humane right because if you don't
check your trap all the time the M could
die in the Trap so
um I think it's a necessary
unfortunately
uh these should not be banned in my
opinion because as they said they are
intelligent and once they get wind of
how you're trying to um control the
population they think they come up with
rodents and then we have to come up with
another solution to try and uh control
that population as far as I understood
too I mean there are a lot of people who
just for ethical reasons or whatever
their reasons will not buy these anyway
and I think you know there's a lot of
public education going on too as to what
is an appropriate means to trap or
control rodents and people can decide
for themselves I I think um rather than
Banning them um there are there are
definitely uh ways to educate people to
say what what's a good way what's not a
good way what works for you in terms of
what you can use to to um trap or
control
roadin and um I think you know instead
of banning it let the market decide
there are going to be stores that won't
sell them and they are going to be uh
people who won't buy them so represent
Duty thank
you uh in my opinion Banning something
like this forces into industry um to um
make changes and to come up with
innovative ways um to tackle the problem
and I would say you know the world
didn't cave in when we banned
DDT but we did it for a reason because
we knew that that pesticide was very
very harmful I believe it was to Bald
Eagles or whatever so I would be in
favor of this bill um I think there are
other options uh we killed rodents 20 30
40 100 years ago when we didn't have
glue traps and people still existed um
and I again I think it forces the
industry to come up with uh better more
Humane um ways of solving a
problem thank you representative duty
but you know I would also submit that um
because there are many people who won't
purchase the and stores that won't sell
them that the industry is indeed still
looking for a better mouse trap and they
are coming up
with better and in more Innovative means
to control um the rodent population as
well so I don't know
that that banning them would would or
not Banning them would dissuade these
companies from coming up with other
different mechanisms to do this so just
my two cents representative Howard um I
think that uh if with education there
would you know if people there if people
who are worried about the suffering of
rodents um learn that that that this is
a not the the fastest way for a mouse to
die um they're not going to buy them I
think that I think that if we if there's
information about what exactly happens
with these traps there will be self-
selecting segment of society that just
won't buy them and um and I and I sort
of agree with you madam chair that that
it sort of it should be left to that I
think thank you representative K thank
you and like I said it does say here on
this most may still be alive when trap
is checked please
humanely uh euthanize before disposing
of but personally because in agriculture
i h have ultrasonic I use peppermint oil
it's not a I think these have been in my
closet for I don't know how many years
um but anyways but I need all the tools
available at my
disposal BEC and because I have dogs I'm
very
cognizant of and when I had other
animals I was very cognizant because um
need to be sure of what I'm using is not
going to be talking toic to any of those
also so these are non-toxic to other
animals also um I'm just going to throw
that out there but yes there are a lot
of things that you can try peppermint
oil
ultrasonic the the
traps um but the rodent population up in
my area and I used to go to a greenhouse
and I was talking with a farmer you know
he very large supplied uh vegetables and
flowers to a lot of people and I was in
the greenhouse and I'm like I there was
a
rat and I said what's going on he goes
we never had rats this
population is heading north and is on
the rise and it is a public health uh
issue the so I just want everyone to
understand that they are a public health
issue also represent has
thank you madam chair I don't think I
have a compelling
argument against what appears to be the
majority I just think it's a bad look I
think you know somebody wants us to ban
something that's
inhumane and we have all the
intellectual arguments about why we
shouldn't do it and I'm struggling to
get there um although I can't refute any
of the perfectly reasonable arguments I
don't know how you um exterminate them
humanly I mean that's the conundrum from
the beginning yeah I I just I think it's
a bad look it it just doesn't set well
with me call me a softy you
know I'm struggling with it I I a tool
in the tool boox well let's get better
tools you know let is science not
Advanced enough to give us something
better than this I'm
struggling thank you representative
Kenny yes thank you um commissioner
Jasper made a really good suggestion
yesterday he said if you have pets
around and you're afraid that inside
using those glue things um boards to put
it in a box and cut a hole so that the
mouse can get in but nothing else can
get in so I
the traps that are set with bait have a
small hole so only the mice can get in
and nothing else so if the if the
packaging said made that
suggestion you you make you know you put
it inside a box I mean it's still I
think that the glue I would rather have
had the service that came in to our
house and put the bait traps down had
used the glue ones our house stunk with
we have an old part of the house the
mice died in the walls and it was months
it's months and it still smells so I
would rather have had the glue traps and
been able to empty them myself and I've
because I have chickens and I've had
rats and because I've had vs in the
garden um I I know how to you know
humanely and for for what the
destruction that rodents can do um sorry
but it I I know it's awful to put an
animal down and I don't like to do it
but you have to it's it's
farming that's my
opinion represent Howard um I don't know
how long mice live like what is the what
is the lifespan of a mouse because and
and Mixie of course know
uh most lifetime is ballpark one to two
years oh unless they're snatched up by a
hawk or a snake or something
right and in the and in that time how
many how many reproductive Cycles do
they have just out of
curiosity every 21 days and it's usually
what like five to six mice per every 21
days your
additional
all right I'm I think we're we're pretty
much uh done hashing that around and I
know um we are not supposed to uh be
hearing another bill until what do we
got here 11 o' so I guess I uh
miscalculated
that unfortunately so we have a half
hour um and uh I'll just invite you all
to go catch up on some um other phone
calls or texts or whatever and uh we'll
see you back at 11
o' thank you everyone appreciate all the
great
discussion oh I also want to thank
everybody for getting their um their
committee reports into me in such a
timely
manner
you
okay it's a little after 11 um we're
waiting for one or two people from the
committee so
uh we'll get underway
those
we all
set good afternoon I mean good morning
still
hello
uh yeah welcome everybody back back to
environment and
agriculture uh today is dog
day we will be reviewing um four four
bills having to do with dogs
today I'll Pi sure um open the hearing
for HB
1316 relative to co-ownership of
dogs and I welcome representative
McKenzie to come and introduce the this
bill along with an a proposed
amendment so um you have the floor thank
you very much uh my name is uh for the
record my name is Mark McKenzie I am uh
State Rep from District 40 which is five
ws in the city of
Manchester uh this bill
1316 uh uh I'm I can offer the amendment
now if you'd like all of you I think
with the exception may I think everybody
should have a copy in front front of
them uh but the amendment is important
in the sense that it uh it is in
response to some questions that I have
relative to uh how people get access to
information so I can take that either we
can talk about that now or we can talk
about that um what would your preference
be um well I'd like you to talk about um
the bill and what problem you're seeking
to solve and
how your Amendment will do that all
right thank you this is a uh a problem
that has been ongoing uh in Manchester
uh for some
time and what's going on is uh there are
uh kennels opening up Dog Daycare
operations that are opening up in the
city and the uh on two occasions uh the
the the the city turned down the kennel
permit because it wasn't appropriate for
the zoning area and uh what's going on
is that people have um using
co-ownership as a foil uh against the
zoning ordinances so they basically uh
and I got a case that we uh that went to
district court so what what happens is
that uh the city moved on on this person
let me for the record say um this is my
neighbor and I I get along with them
great they're terrific people I really
like them but they opened up uh after
the after they were denied uh the the
kennel permit uh at a hearing at which
had the whole neighborhood show it up to
uh they decided to move forward uh and
open up the this operation anyways and
what they did is they basically said
when the city moved on them and they
went to court they claimed that they
were the the co-owners of the animals
now I looked at um and I work with AO uh
legislative services to try to find some
definition of what co-ownership would
mean and there's very little on in New
Hampshire are actually uh uh around the
country there's very little uh
information about that but we know the
the the case next to me and then there
was another case uh recently that came
up where uh this person was one wanted
to do the same thing and they declare
co-ownership again so when you declare
co-ownership and you say you own it in
Manchester you can have as many animals
on the property as you want if you own
them now there's restrictions in terms
of noise and all those other kinds of
restrictions that you have but basically
you can do pretty much what you want and
so so we're we're in this situation
where uh when you ask somebody so what
does it mean to be a co-owner does it
mean you simply sign a piece of paper
and you you say well I own the dog or do
you uh have to take some responsibility
for the ownership of that animal which
is what this legislation basically says
now the piece that I took out with the
which the amendment responds to is there
was a number of years ago there was a
state senator from Bedford who passed
the uh legislation which limited access
to the registration records of animals
and in talking to people who are who
come from the business uh and I've had a
few terrific people who've been
counseling me on this is that uh you
really don't want to lift that
restriction uh you don't want to have
access everybody have access to that
information uh there are there are and
you may hear from some other people but
there there's a good reason for that um
there were there was animal rights
organizations and other people who use
that
information uh and so I I thought the
cleanest thing to do was just simply to
take take it out now what happens in um
what happens without that what happens
currently is that the people who can get
access to that information are not the
neighbors they're not the people who
live in the neighborhood they are they
are people who have the enforcement
Authority so police officers can get it
inspectors can get it other people can
get that that
information I'm sorry okay uh but the
general public can't get it so you're in
a situation where um you've got all
these dogs showing up next door or in
another part of the city and you don't
know who who owns the things the city
inspectors go there they say they co-own
it and so it's caused somewhat of a u a
dilemma for the enforcement Authority
within the community and so all this
thing says and and there may be some
other reasons why we want to do this
what this bill essentially says that if
you claim it you there is responsibility
uh connected with that
claim uh and that means that you take
some responsibility not just simply sign
a piece of paper and walk away but if
you want to assume co-ownership then
that comes with certain conditions and
what the legislation basically says you
got to demonstrate that in fact uh you
take care of them in some way that you
you work with the you know you help with
the with the the providing food or
shelter or um or work with them with the
vet or takes takes other responsibility
which is what normal owners would do um
but they but that's not what they want
they simply want to sign the piece of
paper and walk away now the courts uh uh
after a law was passed here the courts
have given um standing to animals in
divorce cases uh so it is it's actually
looked at the terminology is uh but it's
it's actually part of the divorce set so
you can have that co-ownership
environment um so I think what this what
this does is to basically say okay
that's you're going to do it there are
certain conditions need to be met now
all of those conditions may need to be
in the rules as opposed to being uh in
the law but it does basically say you
can't do that unless you really are
co-owning that animal so that
essentially you know that that's what
this is uh there are a number of these
things popping up all over the place if
you to do quick Google search you find
daycare uh Doggy Daycare operations uh
around Manchester and and around other
communities um so this is this is
popping up it's a pretty profitable
business it's 50 probably average $50 a
day um and there's not a whole lot not a
l whole lot of restrictions on it uh so
I think that what we're trying to do um
in Manchester the only board is kind of
in a dilemma about this but what I'm
trying to do and I've been I've told him
about this the chair of the Zone board
and I have been in conversation and uh
they think this would be helpful um
because they I think they're somewhat
frustrated over over this how this is
being in worked so that's um that's
essentially what it does um now you
could say it's a narrow uh Manchester
Bill uh but I would suggest that uh
given the court uh decisions and
legislation was passed here that really
is broader than that that there needs to
be something that really defines what
that term means co-ownership
okay um so let me get this
straight you're claiming that people are
using the the the premise of
co-ownership in order to establish a
Doggy Daycare Center in their
community
in statute there's no way to
prove
otherwise that that's that's my
understanding and legislative Services
looked at this and they said we can't
really find anything they looked around
New Hampshire looked around we have no
um current definition of Doggy Daycare
operations and current statute is that
is that that's probably correct
representative Murray thank you madam
chair um thank you for taking my
question so if I'm understanding this
correctly am I understanding that these
and these folks are establishing a
proprietorship of some type a business
of entity of some type are they then
also applying for co-ownership of the
business entity as they're establishing
it or I'm having a hard time
understanding when when
somebody goes into a business venture
right like that and
then based on your testimony
I'm am I inferring correctly that the
statement you're making is that there
are multiple dogs that are being claimed
as co-ownership and therefore
they are not establishing an actual
legal entity of a business or I I'm
trying to understand sure there were
well there were two cases that um that
have got some attention this is the the
one in uh again my next door a neighbor
good guy um they basically were denied I
don't know that there's any business
actual business in the sense that
they've established themselves they've
registered the business and all those
kinds of I don't know um but they
clearly are I see the cards every day
popping in there uh the other one was
one off of um and I and I have the
information um but it was off of Melrose
Street this woman wanted to open it up
she went to the zoning board the zoning
board was very nervous about it about
granting any kind of of variance for
this particular uh operation the reason
being is that the variance goes with the
property so while you may represent that
you're going I'm just going to have
little dogs when you sell a house and
you got a variance for a daycare it's
Dog Daycare you even have very big dogs
which was the case when they originally
started the one next door to me um they
were jumping over the
fence uh so yeah so that's uh I don't
you know I don't
know repres of Howard um I have thank
you madam chair I have experience with
the um people making claims about dogs
in as being um support dogs and there's
there's actually no proof required
there's no um so I know that it that
these relationships can be sort of um
nebulous um so do you think that this
definition is is I mean how would you
deploy this
definition to to clarify things well I
mean I haven't I I haven't tried to
address that in this legislation but if
that's something that you think needs to
be amended and use this as a vehicle to
do that I'd be open to that what I find
is there were a couple of um issues that
come up with with this there were
breeders um there are breeders and I
don't maybe some in the room now um that
have this relationship during various
times of the dog's life they may be they
may be breeding the dogs or or taking
care of them following the birth of dogs
and people would know much more about
this and I do um so there's one there's
one issue um the other issue that we're
running into is that people using um
they they're saying they're not really
we're not
really we're not really taking care of
them but they're just friends these are
doggy friends but you're getting paid to
take care of the friends uh uh and if
that's the case that goes from being you
know you're running a business and
you're using the animals and so it's a
mess it really is kind of a me and
inspectors I was an inspector in
Manchester Manchester fire for years
it's kind of a this kind of squishy you
know how you get at this is uh is
difficult but I think before we get this
proliferation of uh daycare sentence I
think it's important to try to give some
direction to the community about
this before you um
so so are you looking more for some way
in which municipalities can
control um the operation of a Doggy
Daycare Center in their town I I'm
looking for um for a definition so that
that that we Define what co-ownership
means that's what I'm looking for in
this legislation whether it be in
Manchester Goan or some other community
because it should have some standing
representative Duty thank you Madam
chair thank you for taking my question
so if I have an analogy of like a
daycare center for children y okay so I
go to the zoning board and I say I want
to open a daycare center and they say no
you can't it's not zoned for that so I
bring in five children and I say they're
all my nieces and nephews um so and I'm
just taking care of them for my you know
relatives that's basically what's
happening and and so that's how they're
getting along get getting around and as
long as they don't care about liability
they don't register a business you know
and they just collect the payments yeah
okay so okay thank
you thank you for that I think it's
good so um one of the things that
um I that I'm a little bit puzzled about
with the bill is that uh it doesn't
actually create a definition of
co-ownership and co-ownership of dogs is
uh mentioned in one place in the
statutes which is in the animal cruelty
statutes where uh if someone is being
tried for animal cruelty and there is
evidence of co-ownership
uh then that then that co-owner would if
the animal has to be removed from the
place where the cruelty is happening the
co-owner would be first on the list to
um to to be able to uh take the dog on
as long as that was approved by the
judge who's hearing the case uh so it
wouldn't be like okay well the husband
is being charged so the wife is a
co-owner and therefore you know it would
stay in the same situation that would be
something that a judge would say that
won't work but if it's say a u a dog
that is being bred for show and uh there
are and one person is sort of has C
typically has custody and another person
is the one who takes it to shows or
whatever uh then uh that would be a
situation where that that second person
who's not on the same premises would be
able to uh to have priority in terms of
taking the care taking care of the
animal after um a a charge of animal
abuse uh that's the current the only
place that co-ownership exists in
statute right now um what you're
proposing here doesn't actually create a
diff a definition of it and I'm not sure
that so I'm not sure that this is
necessarily going to
um create enough standing to do what you
want to
do can I respond to that sure absolutely
thank you uh so I went through with
legislative services and I said let's
nail this thing down and they were very
nice and they researched it all all
around the country and and they said you
know the best thing you can probably do
is make this as simple as possible go
into the Committee hearing and take
input from people in the Committee
hearing and perhaps offer um an
amendment so that's that's why this is
not real doesn't have a lot of Bones to
it now some of this stuff as as we know
some of this stuff we pass here and the
rules take over they you know they come
up with certain rules whether or not
this provides enough direction to to
wherever this lands for for addition
rules I and I'm also willing to amend
this thing um but I don't think we
should just I I think there should be
some uh reasonable way to
determine um who owns this animal and
what the responsibility is that's what
I'm trying to do here and and look I'm
way out of my wheelhouse here I I come
from the labor committee uh I've never
dealt with this uh these kinds of issues
um but I did try as best I could and
there's a file right here of all the
back and forth see the let us say
Services myself representative Murray
thank you madam chair um and thank you
for taking my question I'm just sort of
thinking about based on representative
bixby's comments and and your testimony
about whether or not this is really an
issue about self attestation of
co-ownership or if there is a legal
claim to co-ownership in some other way
through an official record or a
documentation
through uh you know whether it is uh an
animal like Club registration where
co-owners are listed on an official
document somewhere or that type of thing
is that the desire that you're trying to
see is something more official than a
self attestation to say yes oh like
we're
co-owners yeah I mean you know I I think
that there's been some testimony some
questions and some uh
input but you know I think it's easy to
understand co-ownership if you co-own a
house or you co-own a car or you co-own
some other asset uh that you know if
you're putting that down you got to
claim some responsibility for that and
that's what I'm trying to Define here so
when you make that when you do that it's
has some standing now for the city's
perspective um they need to know this
and it shouldn't be used this kind just
signing a piece of paper and saying well
I own the dog now and and just bypass
his owning audiances which is what's
happening that shouldn't be the
case represent Bixby so I'm also
wondering whether uh the people who are
the the real owners of the dogs uh if
they are saying if they sign a paper
saying you know it's co-owned are they
putting themselves in
Jeopardy uh for having the animal
essentially taken away from
them uh through some sort of a
scam you know I think that that's an
interesting um you know question and the
uh there was legislation passed here and
I have it somewhere but there was
legislation which basically gave animals
standing and divorce um so they become
part of the divorce settlement so what
does this mean if two people own this
animal um all of a sudden they're in
this
mix and I don't know how they straighten
that out quite
frankly well I I did get a um some
um input from uh legal who said that
within the family law context RSA 458
col6a property settlement and divorce
proceedings was amended in 2019 to
include the following provision
regarding
animals um Roman numeral 2- a tangible
property shall include
animals in such cases the property
settlement shall address the care and
ownership of the party's animals taking
into consideration the animals
well-being upon Petition of either party
the court May review and modify the
property settlement agreed to previously
own to previously only as it pertains to
this paragraph So I mean that's really
the only definition of co-ownership that
I know of I don't know that 458 col 16-
yeah and it seems to be explicitly
circumscribed exactly and the courts
pretty much
determine
that the court considers it represented
Howard first I'd like to clarify that I
wasn't suggesting that you add um
service dogs to your definition or
anything like that it's using any more
as an example so um sorry for that
confusion um but I also think that with
absent of context that this um it feels
a little bit like this definition of
ownership or co-ownership is flapping in
the wind a little bit like you know is
it doesn't feel very useful without any
bill um is there any other way that the
municipality can um
control the U having a business I mean
they can they explicitly say in their
zoning ordinances that
um a Doggy Daycare cannot be established
in a specific specific area something
well if I could do I mean does does your
town already have that ordinance in
place yes well they they basically have
zoning audiances or they're what they're
allowable things in different zones of
the city this is not allowable in the
city that's why the people have had to
apply for zoning variants to try to
operate these things and um and again it
turns on what it means to be the coona
and that's how they that's the foil
they've used okay represent Duty
oh I'm sorry representative H Haskins
thank you madam chair if somebody
agregates what the town or municipality
has said why can't they charge them in
some way you know the the variance was
denied here's a case right here uhhuh
and the case this case was the the
inspectors proceeded against them as
they should they did all the research
they pulled out all the records they got
to Superior they got to district court
on the step of District Court the these
people who who were um in violation
according to the city pulled out the
co-ownership slip and say we own these
dogs doesn't seem like that's a legal
document you know you're writing a you
can write anything and sign your name to
it but they're on the registration form
from what I
understand that's this is what's this is
what's happening I think it's crazy too
but that's what's happening represent Dy
um thank you madam chair um is it
possible in in a situation where if you
have a form for co-ownership that it's
um signed by both the owners of the
Doggy Daycare the owners of the dog and
it's notorized I mean because under
notarization don't they have to swear
under penalty of law and wouldn't a
notary have to you have to show proof to
the notary that what you're signing is
correct would could that kind of help
the situation um if I could sure um I I
think that I think that would change the
dynamic I think if people had to put
their name and notorized their name and
but at the same time if it doesn't mean
anything if co-ownership is not defined
is what your responsibility is then I
think it's it doesn't have a lot of
Bones you um you know so I think that's
that's really what the core of this
thing is but no I in fact I have some um
some information in some places where
they actually do that they say this is
what this is say kind of the checklist
that they have but it's very rare around
the country that this this takes place
representative
Kenny yes thank you um do they require
Health certificates for any of these uh
places because if they did that if they
started requiring health certificate
they they would have to claim ownership
and it would be signed by a
veterinarian and I believe there might
be on the bottom I tried to look it up
but I can't remember whether there might
have been a place for co-ownership but
you would have the owner of the dog
because I think they do use that in
breeders do you remember that Lisa I
don't know if you remember that but
anyway I don't know if they if they
required health
certificates to go into that
daycare um then they'd have the names
that's
my representative Murray thank you madam
chair um
one other question that I had was around
um the total amount of animals or dogs
that we're talking about here are we
talking three animals that are
potentially you know all co-owned
together or are we talking 30 animals
that are being claims of co-ownership
what are we talking about here in school
sure I mean my understanding is that if
you own the dog you can have as many
dogs on your property as you want
provided they don't violate the
ordinance of newes or or some of the you
know health issues and things like that
so you really have no control once that
you cross that line
um yeah so I don't know where the
limitation is in that case for the
have representative H Haskins thank you
madam chair so I don't know very much
about this um does a breeder have to
have
uh
certificates uh
licenses yeah I mean I think some there
may be some people here that are bers
that can answer answer that particular
question so we wouldn't be leaving them
off the page and getting them involved
in this co-ownership thing yeah I mean
I'm happy uh I'm happy to um work with
them um if if there's some conditions
that they have that they need some
relief from this proposal and I think we
could work with them may I follow up
sure so if my son takes his dog to a
neighbor I
believe and she has uh what looks like a
business to me you know she's got a Fen
in
backyard um she takes more than his
dog um they happen to live in Denver so
depending on what the city's ordinance
says
she either is or isn't registered as a
business and so I think we haven't
nailed down how to define co-ownership
yet um but it seems as though the
different localities might have
different zoning ordinances that might
cover this and I think you're saying
that we don't Manchester doesn't if I
could M sure
uh I uh legislative Services looked all
over the place and they couldn't find
any evidence of of how this is properly
defined um and that's why you know and I
think the court may offer some
instruction or or for us in terms of uh
what it what this means um so we might
be able to work on that but no I
don't I I I think the way it is now if
you say you're co-owning you can have as
many as you want now I don't know the
business thing is a whole another thing
if you're taking money where's the money
going that's a whole another issue but
you can't go to the zoning board get
denied at the zoning board and then turn
around and open it anyways which is
exactly what's happening represent
Bixby yeah I'm just thinking that we do
have someone in uh who is uh in the
audience here who is
uh knowledgeable about the way that uh
breeders and uh kennels kennels manage
animals and I think maybe uh maybe we
could have her come up and help us
out all right well thank you for
introducing this bill um and I guess we
Holmes yeah you we'll have Angela
too
thank
you make you take
your so as I understand the um the
sponsor uh bill would with any Amendment
not create any kind of publicly
available list showing co-ownership
um
and all they're looking all he's looking
for really is to have some sort
of um definition or statement regarding
so I'll tell you the term co-ownership
I'm sorry my name's Nancy Holmes for the
record and I'm here from New Boston and
yes I've been a breeder as was president
of a dog Club um I know a lot about how
things work I don't know everything uh
although I try uh anyway the the term
co-ownership in the purebred dog world
is a contract between two people to own
a dog together and this may mean say
you've got beautiful show dog that could
win everything in the world if only you
had a box of money and I come along and
say I have a box of money I'd be happy
to fund that but I want my name on that
dog while we're showing it so that
everybody could see that I have the
wonderful dog um another reason for
co-ownership would be for breeding
purposes you know I'm willing to help
you out doing a litter but I want my
name on the litter too so we will change
the registration of the dog to reflect
two people own it and that's the same
with if you're doing the show
co-ownership it's the same deal you
change the registration of the dog with
AKC to show that two people or more I've
seen up to five in some really top dogs
um so so that's that's what it is in the
pure bread world now um I'm not sure
that this Doggy Daycare is is handling
pure breads only um or AKC pure breads I
know that's how it works for them I am
concerned that somebody would be
claiming co-ownership of a dog and not
be able to provide proof that they have
licens the dog which also provides proof
that the dog has had rabies vaccination
because you can't get a dog license
unless the dog has had a rabies
vaccination um I think if the person is
claiming the dog is a co-owner and the
dog resides with them they should be
able to provide proof of those two
things the RAB certificate and the dog
license in their name or in both
person's name it wouldn't just be
um okay so I've got I've got a dog and
you're claiming it we co-own it it
wouldn't be just my name on the license
it wouldn't be just my name on the Raby
certificate because we co-own the dog
that often means we share expenses when
something is co-owned um so out in the
world where there's um everything in the
world is possible for a mix um I I'm not
sure exactly how the person can claim
co-ownership I would think they would be
able to show a um legal document that
there were two people who in in
agreement were were owning the dog
together um I don't know if the people
who are doing the Doggy Daycare
understand that if they've signed over
and become a co-owner with the owner of
the Doggy Daycare care that means that
they are liable if something happens if
the Doggy Daycare person makes a mistake
and somebody gets bitten and all that
that they are going to be liable for the
um any lawsuits as well as the Doggy
Daycare person you know say your dog
bites you know somebody else's on the
premises um it's not going to be the
Doggy Daycare operator who's just on the
line if the people are co-owners with
the Doggy Daycare owner I think I really
believe that this is a zoning issue um
in in Manchester I at somewhere along
the way I read a description of a
um I think it was a set of cond
condominiums or tow houses where they
had a limit on how many dogs you could
have you could have one dog of your own
and up to three days at a time for I
don't know if it was a week or a month
you could babysit somebody else's dog
but you could only do it for one dog you
could only do it for a certain number of
days and that was to make sure that the
condo area didn't fill up with five
million barking little dogs but um I
thought that seemed extremely reasonable
that you could limit the number of of
dogs that were visiting for care um and
that might help take care of the problem
but again I see that as a more of a
zoning issue in one area as a state than
as a Statewide issue um I I know it was
said that nobody knows what co-ownership
means I think the place to look for that
information is AKC because that's the
only place I know of it actually being
in use um I don't know um I think the
people are very clever at trying
this you know but I I think you should
be able to ask them to provide proof of
co-ownership
um or proof or if the dog resides there
provide proof of Licensing and rabies
information because that's a public
health issue thank you representative
Murray thank you madam chair do you
share any concern about you know
somebody laying claim to co-ownership
that actually has no right to claiming
co-ownership and then there's also that
facet of the conversation yeah I I think
that that could turn really really bad
in ways they aren't anticipating like I
said all it would take is one bad
incident with a neighbor's kid or
something and poof everybody involved
loses their house you with lawsuits I it
could be I just don't I think they're
thinking this is a way to get around so
I can make money I'm also wondering if
they're running a business and taking in
money uh they registered with the state
as a business um are they reporting all
their income to the IRS boy that that
would really really ruin them send the
IRS their way and say hey they're taking
money under the table for doing
this but yeah I can see repercussions if
they with coers any other
questions represent Bixby yeah so it's
it's a been it's been a while since I've
looked at the uh group dog license
statutes but I'm wondering if
uh if that
the excuse me the who um rep McKenzie uh
mentioned that uh the um when the person
had was brought to court they showed a
uh a dog license with their name on it
and I'm wondering if that was a
potentially a group dog license where
it's a little bit harder to train to
track exactly which dogs there are but
I'm wondering off how that would work if
you had multiple co-owners of different
animals be ugly uh the in terms of the
group license I know I had to to give
the name and information on every single
dog that I had at my home and I had to
provide their rabies vaccination
information a group license doesn't just
mean have however many you want with no
record of what you have I mean you can
slide some stuff around where you only
have to re redo your group license once
a year you could slide around you got a
new puppy an old dog died you still got
the same number but you next year you're
going to have to update which dog is
which and approve the rabies
vaccinations well I know uh
representative Bixby I'm looking at the
section four 466 colon 6 on group
licenses and um there are five
Provisions here one of which the last
one upon request an owner or keeper
shall receive numbered license tags for
each dog included under the owners or
keeper group license so I mean there's
that you could ask for uh or the
municipality could ask proof for group
ownership through um the license tag
numbers and um it also says the owner or
keeper of five or more dogs shall
annually by April 30th pay the required
fee and obtain license authorizing the
owner or keeper to keep the dogs upon
the premises described in the license so
in the license is also the residence or
where the premises where the dog is
being
kept
um so you know there's there's a number
of things in the group license here
which I would imagine the municipality
could use to prove co-ownership
is that true yeah or ownership you know
U the thing is I know that when I got a
group license I did know not ask them
for an individual tag for each of my
dogs because I had show dogs and my show
dogs did not wear collars at all they're
all microchipped but Town didn't care
about that but because you don't want a
ring around the neck of fur that is
rubbed from a collar you just don't you
don't leave um collars on your showd
dogs or at least we didn't at the time I
had a long haired breed and it would be
really obvious that you know ring around
the collar um so I did not request I got
um they usually gave me like one tag or
I may have asked for two for my for my
two big dogs but the little dogs didn't
get a taged but I still had to list
every single dog I owned under that
group license and I had to prove to the
town hall that every single one of them
had had their rabies
vaccine okay thank you yeah any other
representative H Haskins thank you madam
chair what's the enforcement of that was
the enforcement of that you can't get a
license unless you can prove rabies
vaccination so somebody has to find out
that you don't have a
license there's a possibility that you
would not not have a license but if
somebody's claiming they have all these
co-owned dogs on their premises and that
they're taking care of them they should
all be licensed to win proof of rabies
vaccination represent
Biby yeah so um
this this bill might not be the the the
the right way of going about it but
would you what would you feel about
having a definition of co-ownership in
state law I think that would be really
difficult because I'm getting the
impression that what I think of as
co-ownership which is a mutual
beneficiary relationship between two
people over ownership of a dog a
purebred dog for that matter is very
different from how they're throwing the
word around around in this Doggy Daycare
case so I think it would be difficult to
do represent Murray thank you madam
chair and I guess uh to representative
bixby's point I didn't we just establish
the fact that there is a legal
definition for animals and statute with
regard
to um
ownership this is yes we did with regard
to for the divorce yeah the the as we
said in RS say 458 Co
16-a um with regard to family law and
property settlement and divorce
proceedings they said that tangible
property shall include
animals um but but there's nothing there
that actually says Pro that that there's
proof of co-ownership right and the
other thing is that I believe that the
last line in that in in that statute
says that uh this what what what is
mentioned here only applies to this
particular case yeah to
right representative Howard thank you
madam chair um so uh I think that maybe
I don't I would defer to the more
knowledgeable people on this but I think
that maybe the uh definition might be
stronger if it has some reference to
residence or where the dog resides I
think that um you're mentioning of a a
of the um of it being a zoning issue he
already sort of um established that they
they had been turned down because of a
zoning problem right so and so they're
using this end run around it if if there
was a mention of of where the dog
actually resides even if it includes two
places um that that might make the
ownership definition stronger do you
think or um that that that could help in
determining you know where the dog
resided and and whether it should be be
there what I'm thinking
is Manchester could do something like
saying you can have own as many dogs as
you want you got them licensed you got
their rabies vaccination and you can
change something so that you can babysit
X number of dogs like if you wanted to
take your mother-in-law's dog while she
went to Florida um something like that
um and limit the amount of time that
that dog could be there so that you have
your own dogs you have a dog that your
babysitting for you know somebody a
relative or a friend but you can only
have one or maybe two dogs to babysit at
a time and you can only have them for so
many days out of a week or a month I
think that would resolve that Doggy
Daycare setup pretty good yeah I don't
know how you can enforce that though I
mean that seems like it would be really
difficult to determine how long
anybody's had a dog at their place or
how many hours a day or repr presum dsy
yeah um yeah I agree that this would
probably something that could be done on
the municipal level but I mean basically
if we just look at the definition and do
like a proof of co-ownership of of
animal co-ownership consists of you know
and then I mean it could be you know a a
notorized document with the name and
address of of both co-own you know and
then just listed out um I think that
that would give it some teeth and it
probably could be done at the municipal
level unless we wanted to take that on
as a state level but again you know I
think I always find this interesting
because I chair a Conservation
Commission that I call an urban
Conservation Commission because it's so
different than conservation Commissions
in small communities and it's the same
thing here that this is a an issue issue
that is more likely to occur in our
cities um because you know of our close
proximity you our our neighborhoods and
people wanting to open up something you
know for incremental income so um I
don't know if we need it Statewide but I
think the cities definitely need to look
at it right I think there may be a way
to to to define something good that the
cities could all use to add to their
zoning I don't believe this is said I
don't think this is going to get you
anywhere um I think the um the Crux of
the matter here is they're saying the
dogs are co-owned the my big question
for that co-ownership is where do the
dogs reside and where are they legally
licensed and we you know and with proof
of rabies vaccinations because it's if
it's from Massachusetts you know or if
it's from Bedford instead of Manchester
you know it it's just a it's just a
different thing um you know it's it's
very tricky like I said I think the
people who are running that Doggy
Daycare are very
clever representative Bixby so do you
happen to know if when uh someone is uh
establishing co-ownership of a pure
breed dog whether uh they need to do a
health certificate uh to uh indicate
that transfer of that creation of
co-ownership no I don't believe so but
there quite often there are lawyers
involved because the co-ownership um
might be that I will take care of all
Veterinary bills or we will split all
Veterinary bills or um the dog will
reside with you for two years and after
that it will come back to me for
breeding purposes so there's there's all
kinds of I mean some of these contracts
are are really uh amaz and like I said
there's often a lawyer involved it's not
just a hi yeah you can be
co-owner representative Marie I know up
until this point we've talked about
individual people in co-ownership but
are there circumstances in which there
is a business entity that also lays
claim to ownership of an animal or
co-ownership like if there is a such and
such Corporation yes yeah a Consortium I
I I suppose there could be I'm sorry I
suppose there could be the the biggest
one I've seen and I don't know what the
contract looked like of course is there
were actually five dogs no five people
supporting one dog through the show
circuits and it was a that dog was being
campaigned from one side of the country
to the other so there's a lot of travel
involved a lot of professional handlers
involved and so on um so there was a lot
of I'm sure there was a lot of
contractual obligations and
responsibilities that each person signed
up for when they contributed money to be
part of the this particular dog campaign
and I know it probably sounds very
forign foreign to you all to to have a
dog that is competing like that I know I
never did the poor dogs were stuck with
me in the ring but um it it was uh and I
actually when I had one that became a
world champion I actually sold it to
somebody I knew who could campaign it
the way they wanted to I didn't keep a
co-ownership but it there's
responsibilities that go with the
co-ownership as well as you know the the
pleasure of owning the
dog and and I think each contract would
be different I I believe you know
somebody's mentioned maybe we could do
both parties signing a notorized
statement I think that would work to
have proof that the dog is co co-owned
but you know I'd suggest you run that by
your legal department and see what what
they think okay thank
you uh with that I'd like to call Angela
Ferrari
sure now she's actually currently active
in the show
world
move this out of the way behind you no
I'm
back welcome to dog day at the
environment and agriculture commit right
yeah I couldn't miss this
um hi Angela Ferrari president of dog
owners of the Granite State I think
we've uh dug into a lot on this one I
have a few thoughts and comments just
from what I've been hearing and then
we'll open it up to questions that you
may have um while definitely being
sympathetic to the issue that raised
this bill and trying to find a solution
um we had primarily concerns around
where this documentation was going to go
and the privacy concerns that that would
have about personal information um so
with our dog licenses there is statute
RSA 466 colon
1-d that explicitly states that the
information provided on dog licenses
cannot be sold given out etc etc so that
locks it down and make sure that there's
no privacy concerns with that
information so if we are opening up to
proving co-ownership in some way we need
to make sure that we still have those
privacy safeguards in place um it was
mentioned about the dogs license itself
that seems like a good Avenue that the
municipality could use to confirm
ownership of the dog um obviously in
this case it's not that the dogs are
residing at this particular residence
but coming from another so that does
make that a bit trickier um but there
was a lot of good conversation about the
notaries for co-ownership or different
things like that that I think could be
explored but it does seem that this is
something that should be addressed at
the municipal level rather than here uh
with the
legislature um a question that I did
have which would be for the sponsor is
are the real owners we'll call them the
real owners the ones who are bringing
these dogs to the Doggy Daycare are they
agreeing with the daycare that they the
daycare does co-own these dogs um if
they are participating in this facade of
co-ownership then I think it's going to
get really tricky with the way that this
bill is written regarding
registration um adoption records or
transfer of ownership agreement or
pedigree records the license information
that's listed is the likely one that's
going to be the hardest
to um Swindle somebody with because for
example I co-own all of my puppies I'm a
breeder of doberman's um and the
majority of my puppies that I sell I do
co-own and I do have a contract with the
owners for every single puppy um and for
those that I co-own It explicitly states
that I co-own a name only I do not have
any financial obligation or legal
obligation to the dog as the contract is
written the reason I stay on the dog is
for different reasons as Nancy mentioned
uh related to showing breeding different
things like that it may be uh a person
that you know hasn't purchased for me
before and I may be doing a payment plan
with them and so I'm remaining on the
registration until that payment is in
full different things like that um so
that I have the ability to take the dog
back if we were to have a dispute over
the dog or the contract or payments
however with my experience with that it
is ex extremely easy to add a co-owner
to a registration so if these real
owners of these dogs are conspiring with
the daycare and that is the direction
they want to go they'll easily be able
to get their names on registrations they
can even have a contract that states
it's a name only different things that
could protect them down the road if
something were to come up would they go
through all of that trouble I'm not sure
there are fees associated with getting
on the registration of a dog they're
fairly minimal I wouldn't expect it to
be more than $40 per dog so that's about
one day's worth of daycare and if it's
worth it to them um to be trying to do
this it's likely that they could do that
so I do think that it makes it difficult
to even prove beyond what we're trying
to do that these dogs are truly co-owned
by this
person
um and I think that was those were kind
of my questions and thoughts that I had
and I know we've had a lot of other
answers from other people but if you had
further questions I would be happy to
them so do you think that it would be
more helpful in this situation
if say uh Doggy Daycare is identified as
a particular activity
enumerated in statutes
somewhere that the Secretary of State
you know you'd have to register in order
to have a doggy
daycare and that would be the mechanism
that would allow municipalities to point
to that being a
business yeah I think it's interesting
that we don't have that defined
especially with the popularity of doggy
day cares these days I don't know if
they are just establishing themselves as
a business and in order to sell and
offer services and have a facility and
all of the things that come along with
the larger scale doggy daycares um it
may be a good Avenue it would lead into
more things too as far as inspections
potentially and making sure that their
facilities are appropriate to be housing
the animals depending on the level of
daycare that they're
offering okay any other
questions seeing none thank you very
much and I guess this is something the
committee is going to have
absolutely
believe so that might one they are not
and okay so we'll have to look at
statutes that said that mention boarding
and see if we can insert maybe doggy
daycares into that as well I don't
know we'll have to look at that
represent dsy but I I think the whole
issue here is that how can you deny me
the right to take care of my nephews and
my niece's dogs okay and I think that's
how they're so they're not so they're
indicating that this is not a business
I'm just taking care of dogs for friends
and that type type of thing and and
that's the real issue but I think it I
mean I think to the it's obvious to
everybody that they are running a
business the IRS is the best place to
all right thank you all right I'm seeing
as there's no other um discussion on
this bill I'm going to close out uh the
hearing on hb1 1316 and we will adjourn
o'clock
fun
uh members from environment agriculture
if you're out in the
oh
yeah
gra that's not really it okay you have a
road block there
right okay you yes I am I'm I'm acting
thank you today thank
you okay thank you Mr
Johnson all right we are going to get
started for excuse me environment and
agriculture welcome this afternoon to
dog
days and we will be starting
1173 I'm going to open up that
hearing and I am going to invite
representative roachford here to
us no I'm good I'm good I'm good I got
it good afternoon Madame chair and
members of uh environment and
agriculture it's nice to be back here I
heard last week you're having dog week I
had to come back
so this is H this is great so before you
uh for the record my name is David
Rochford I'm represent Grafton 1 I live
in
Littleton um before you today you've got
House Bill
1173 and I just want to give you a
little background how I got involved in
in this it typically is not something
that I um focus my legislative efforts
on but I got a call from a a um a
concerned citizen of the North Country
um this person I've known for for a
number of years and he is described a
situation that occurred to him over the
last year that was uh you know really he
felt troubling and really didn't give a
whole lot of um um opportunity for
justice if you will uh he is an attorney
and I told him hey if I introduce this
bill you're going to have to come
testify and I've introduced the bill and
uh he got called to a court hearing so
he's uh he is not here but he did write
a letter which I've given to you um uh
and I would encourage you to read it
because it really gives the background
uh for for where this bill is coming
from uh I'm going to kind of just give
you some of the highlights but again I
would encourage you to to take a look at
the the the letter this all went back uh
about a year ago um when he was walking
his dogs in a rural area he lives in a
rural road in Lancaster and uh his dog
was attacked by a neighboring dog and it
was a violent attack um it left his dog
injured ultimately he thought it was was
dead dead and uh but it did come back um
and you know looking for for you know
some some justice in there
and the the concern that he had the
problem that he had didn't necessarily
happened after the first attack but
shortly after his attack there was
another attack and another attack and uh
and there was a small Municipal P fine
that was paid but but that was that was
it um clearly a dog that attacks people
or other animals U four or five times is
uh we would all think probably something
needs to be done but again as an
attorney he examined the law and uh
found there wasn't a lot of recourse
with that so before you I have uh 1173
and it's a one one paragraph um and it
starts on the new it's uh part of RSA
46631 and inserts a new paragraph
starting at line eight it just and again
I feel that this is a very reasonable
approach to it um it talks about a
domestic animal
that which that attacks a human being or
a dog that attacks a human being or
another um domestic animal where a
puncture or tearing of skin occurs so
this isn't a nip this isn't uh you know
a puppy uh doing doing things that
puppies do um but this is where there
was an actual bite uh going on and if it
happen two or more times within a 12
Monon period so again frequent I mean
it's not if you got a dog I think I mean
I I've I've had dogs that bit once twice
in their whole lifetime um but this is
this is here we made it so there is a a
pattern of biting
established um and if that happens uh so
you got to have the puncture of skin and
two or more times in a 12month period
That's evidence that the dog is vicious
and the dog will be taken into custody
by the the the police Constable or other
persons authorized and the court shall
order the dog euthanized so um it uh it
provides a pathway for vicious dogs to
be removed from the community and the
threat to the public eliminated um so
that's that's the bill uh and I'd be
happy to take some questions okay thank
you
um any questions from the committee
questions representative Howard um is
this does this need to be a state law I
know that in my town I had a similar
experience to your wife's to the the
person's wife um where the dog attacked
my dog was able to pull him off before
he was but he had him by the throat
right and um when we reported it to the
police the the police said that that dog
needed to be restrained and if he was
ever in an off leash not even just was
attacking another dog with off leash he
would be taken and euthanized so um so
and that's at the Town level do we do we
really need a state CLA for this yeah
and again this is uh this
is this this the person that asked me to
put this is an attorney and he he
examined and and studied the law and he
felt that this is the most adequate
solution for for a circumstance where
there's been a proven history of of
vicious dog
attacks any other
questions representative
dsy representative I I don't know this
but uh can vicious dogs be
rehabilitated uh I mean especially if
they're like abused or anything like
that or is it once they go in that
direction that's
it uh that I don't know I'm uh I I I I'm
not a dog expert uh by any means so I
wish I could answer your question I
don't have an answer for
questions well I know no representative
um Bixby sorry yeah so um representative
Howard mentioned that uh in her town the
uh the solution that the the local law
enforcement suggested was uh requiring
that the dog be restrained which seems
to be a um perhaps less drastic solution
than um than
euthanasia would you be um comfortable
with having a a a less severe punishment
for the dog you know I think the um
the the the anything that could prevent
this from happening for a dog that's
been shown to be vicious and have a
pattern I think would be a very
agreeable solution I mean the goal of
this is to
prevent vicious dogs from continually
attacking um people or or other animals
so if the committee feels that that
would uh uh accomplish that um by all
means I think that would be a um an
adequate
solution according to current statute
though and and we acknowledge in in law
that you know there are there can be um
if if the if a animal runs after chases
bicycles Motor Vehicles um if
they um growl snaps that runs after or
chases any person so those are those are
dogs that are considered a menace a
nuisance or
vicious um and and and the law already
alludes to the fact and acknowled
acknowledges that they're the owners
hold liability to that um so it would
seem to me that you just report that to
the authorities and the authorities
would take action to make sure that the
dog owner either restrains the animal or
watches the animal or you know somehow
corrects this situation from happening
again yeah so I think that um and we
discussed that and I think he he
highlighted that in his letter in that
you he went to the the authorities and
it was a fine and the dog owner just
paid the fine I mean they they were of
means they didn't care what it cost and
they would pay the fine and pay the fine
and pay the fine and there was a pattern
of that so this uh the goal would be to
elevate it up into a serious or more
serious um uh consequence for for
pattern for
multiple and again the the the important
thing of the bill is there's a pattern
it's not a onetime thing it's not a once
every five years it's a it's a pattern
and it's a serious ious of of the attack
you know where there's skin broken
there's a puncture wound um these aren't
minor these aren't minor this isn't
Menace this isn't growling this isn't
chasing this is a you know a vicious uh
assault but but according to the statute
the way it's written now any person who
fails by appropriate action including
but not limited to restraining an animal
from running at large or otherwise
effectively abating a nuisance found
such under the the provisions of this
section or who fails to comply with any
other provisions of this section after
being so ordered shall have the person's
dog taken into custody by the police of
the city Constable of the town or other
person authorized by the town and such
disposition made of the dog as the court
May order so there's a remedy here I
mean if if the person can pay a fine but
obviously if this is something that's
ongoing yeah um it would I would imagine
law enforcement would get involved here
and say look it you're not doing your
job we're going to confiscate your
animal right and and I wish that he was
here to to address that because I know
he did the research on it but I will
have him follow up with with the
committee to uh explain why those
remedies weren't weren't to his
satisfaction thank you representative H
Haskins thank you madam chair thank you
representative would you imagine that
different municipalities have different
uh enforcement measures depending on
their personnel and perhaps how their
um authorities undertake these
situations yeah I would I mean just in
my district in Littleton Littleton is a
more I want to say Urban it's not far
from Urban but uh it's got neighborhoods
in a main street in a business section
and then in my my town of Lyman that I
there's really the Lyman town hall and
there's is really not a whole lot of uh
um um development if you will so I would
imagine there are different uh resources
available locally from Littleton versus
Lyman who doesn't have a police officer
doesn't have you know don't have a
police station um whereas Littleton is a
much more developed area so yeah I would
I would agree with that yes thank you
representative Murray thank you madam
chair um thank you for taking my
question um given that it um an RSA 446
colon 31 uh like the chair had mentioned
regarding musling and Restraint of dogs
as a potential remedy do you think that
the court might or could possibly find
um a remedy to be that a a dog be
muzzled and also attend behavior
modification classes or some sort of
other uh remedy that before youth in
Asia yeah and again I I having doing
this on behalf of somebody who is in the
courts every day um you know works in
the courts uh I I would have to imagine
that was pursued uh I don't have a
definitive answer for that but um um
knowing knowing you know a little bit of
the background and and how we got here
um I would be surprised if those Avenues
were pursued uh uh
or surprised if those ad those Avenues
did not I'm surprised if he didn't try
all the Avenues that available to him
that's probably what I should say
represent viby so you said that that
there's a fine levied was that fine
levied by the municipality or was that
levied by the court uh I believe that I
don't I don't have an answer for that
okay so I'm just I'm just trying to
figure out whether this was actually
seen by a judge who uh determined the
disposition or whether it was not
actually brought to court because that
could make a difference in terms of the
section of law that the uh Sheriff
person cited uh the the the difference
between having it settled with in just
just by law enforcement or settled uh in
court makes a really a big difference
and uh one of the things I'm since we
have do have that section of law it does
give the the uh the court a fair amount
of discretion in terms of what they deem
a remedy uh so uh I I I feel like I'm
hesitant
to uh to to require youth in Asia and uh
have it supered the what could be done
with with judicial supervision sure and
I will you know I'm taking notes here
and I'm going to make sure that these
get followed up you know from his
experience and where where he went on
that
certainly representative
smart did your friend um talk to the
state bet at all to see what the state
statute was on vicious dogs or dogs I I
I I don't know if he talked to the vet
per se but I know that he did research
you know his did his own research on the
on the statute because the the line that
you put in section B was that line 8
through 12 is the law already as far as
I know at least it was 50 years ago when
field yeah that's when when we work we
worked with OS and said this is where we
want they they it's already they added
that well no they added the the stuff in
bold 8 through 12 is what what OS added
in the bill in LSR yeah that covers the
law though well RSA 466 colon
31-a has a number of penalties for first
assum first offense
$25 second offense $100 and the uh $100
for the first vicious offense um $400
for the second or subsequent vicious
offense is committed within 12 months so
there is a schedule of you know of um
um they have also the any person who
pays a civil forfeiture specified in the
above paragraph two times in any
12-month period according to the records
of the town or city clerk may not pay a
civil forfeiture for subsequent
violations um and and but she'll have
those cases disposed of in District or
min ipal court
so as as there are subsequent
attacks uh it would seem that that they
would eventually end up in court with
this and the court would then decide
what would happen What would have to
happen with the
animal so I think this is all pretty
well covered in 466 colon
31-a what I'm going to do is I'll take
this back and um you know he he's he's
the one that I said I did this on behalf
of a constituent and we'll sure we'll uh
we'll see if I
maybe
misrepresented but I don't think so I
think I really do think that he covered
it so we'll find out where where he uh
where he's where he's looking for thank
you all right any other
questions no all right thank you very
much I'll call Robert
Johnson from New Hampshire Farm
Bureau thank you for joining us
today
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee for the record Rob Johnson
representing New Hampshire Farm beer was
a federation's policy director thank
you this this bill really grabbed the
attention of our membership when they
saw it for particularly what it could
mean for working dogs do just doing the
jobs job they are are
trained the uh the proposed language we
see is is is is quite
inflexible um I mean two times
regardless of
circumstances as representative Bixby
mentioned earlier there's you know
little discretion there and that the
existing statute does provide that I
wanted to dra also draw to your
attention to another RSA but may I think
address this particular situation if I
understood it correctly that the sponsor
uh cited that's RSA 466 in 28 titled
killing dogs legalized it reads any
person may kill a dog that suddenly
assaults the person while such person is
peaceably walking or riding without the
enclosure of its owner or keeper and any
person may kill a dog that is f that is
found out of the enclosure or immediate
care of its owner or keeper worrying
wounding or killing sheep Lambs fowble
animals and I'll leave my testimony at
that as always appreciate you time and
attention hey thank you any
questions seeing none um I'd like to
obber afternoon chair Ain put your
microphone on good afternoon chair Aon
members of the committee my name is
Stacy oer I'm the New England manager of
government relations for the American
Kennel Club
uh we were founded in 1884 we're a
nonprofit that's widely recognized as an
expert in K9 Health breeding and
training and we advocate for the
purebred dog as a family companion and
promote the ideals of responsible
ownership we represent over 5,000 dog
clubs nationally including 13 here in
New Hampshire which represent thousands
of constituent dog owners we too have
concerns about HB
1173 and the way it's uh been drafted in
terms of of requiring the court to label
as vicious and euthanize any dog that
attacks humans or domestic animals
resulting in the puncture or tearing of
skin two or more times in a 12-month
period uh if you read the bill it
basically is um referring in line 10
that this shall be per se evidence so
strict liability and un we do support
and believe dog owners should be
responsible for their dogs and we do
support laws that establish a fair
process by which specific dogs are
identified as dangerous based on stated
measurable actions and imposing
appropriate penalties on irresponsible
owners um we do believe it's important
to establish a well- defined method for
dealing with dogs proven to be dangerous
but as written
1173 would eliminate the Court's Fair
process of determining on a caseby Case
basis whether the dog was provoked
engaged in the protection of other
animals or property or its own um its
own domain or they were responding to a
situation where the victim might have
been trespassing on the owner's property
so there are a number of conditions or
circumstances when a dog might attack
and one could consider that as
appropriate or reasonable uh for them to
do so and our belief is that as written
the current law would allow that type of
discretion in front of the court I'm I'm
not clear and listening to the bill
sponsor whether or not um the
individuals who had this unfortunate
situation of repeated attacks were
unable to uh file a complaint in court
or not after understanding that civil
fines had been paid for the um prior
prior uh injuries um but by doing so and
making this basically just strict
liability uh the the bill fails to
recognize working dogs such as police
canines for instance livestock Guardian
dogs and others um so our understanding
who have adopted ordinances that may and
I'm just speaking from my experience in
reviewing um municiple ordinances and
statutes across New England um based on
an attack there may be conditions around
confinement for instance uh restricting
the uh release of a dog from confinement
only by uh someone who's not a minor uh
requiring additional homeowners
insurance you know certain Provisions if
there is a pattern of uh of a dog
engaging in inappropriate vicious
conduct um and that due process or Fair
process in terms of some model
language can in fact include a process
where that label is even removed after
behavior modification or or other
training so I'm just sharing that from
what I've seen in other jurisdictions if
it's of um benefit to the committee
questions thank you that was a lot I
day good afternoon Madam chair m members
of the committee Angela Ferrari again
dog owners of the Granite State um the
great thing about not having to go first
is so many important facts have already
been stated to you that I don't need to
repeat um just going to highlight a few
things with comparing this bill to
current law um it seems that as it's
already been stated under 466 colon 31a
penalties that we do have a Avenue to
address these type of issues um already
mentioned in there is if within a
12-month period vicious behavior is seen
within uh up to two times that this can
be brought to the court and I think it's
more important to know that we do have
that Avenue to pursue where we can have
a court assess the
situation um because right now we're
where we would be removing Juris Juris
judicial excuse me discretion and
undermining the due process rights of
the owners of these dogs if we were
immediately going to jump to euthanasia
in the case of these situations um as
stated by others there are often times
instances where it may have been
appropriate for the puncture or tearing
of skin um by a dog that wouldn't result
in the need for euthanasia necessarily a
few other things that came to mind um as
I was thinking about this bill is what
about the case of a dog fight where two
different individuals may be intervening
to separate the dogs and both were bit
uh or their skin was torn during that
event and that would actually be two
different instances of that type of
um um tearing of skin in a 12mon period
would then they be able to go to the
court and say this dog needs to be used
IED even though it was only in the case
of One technical event but two different
people had their skin torn um and you
know dogs do fight I have Doberman um
although they generally always get along
there are the cases when they decide to
have a little scuffle and I tell you
that I don't try to get in between them
um because they're not going to
intentionally bite me or hurt me but
it's they're animals they're in the
moment and it could happen happen and if
there is a dog fight you often see two
people who are going to try and get in
there separate the dogs and put
themselves at risk that could put the
dog or dogs at Jeopardy um if this bill
was to move forward there's other cases
where one dog may instigate a fight um
and this is why I don't bring my dogs to
dog parks one having Doberman if
something if one dog starts something if
my dog was to finish it they're going to
be the one that looks like the problem
dog just because the stigmatism of the
breed but in general if one dog was to
instigate a situation but other dogs are
protecting themselves and they were to
in turn bite the dog that instigated the
situation um if or if multiple dogs were
to instigate you could also then have
instances where now we're starting to
rack up potential charges against the
dog within that 12-month period and
these would just be examples of things
that you know can happen happen with
animals um that could be making these
type of decisions for themselves just to
protect themselves mentioned previously
with the working dogs um by Mr Johnson
from the Farm Bureau their job is to
protect the property and there are
domestic animals involved in that
situation as well so not to continue on
uh too much further I would take any
questions but we do feel that this is
already covered well under the laws that
we already have in place thank
you any questions from Miss
Ferrari no thank you very much
appreciate it um would call now uh Nancy
bill
welcome again thank you name's Nancy
Holmes I'm still from New Boston except
if I don't ever go home my husband may
change my mind on that but uh anyway um
I'm here on my behalf and also that of
Jay finy hopefully you all have written
testimony from Jay and he um asked me to
uh correct with you a typo that went was
was in his was in the third paragraph of
his testimony you'll see RSA 431 d a and
it was intended to be
31a so he um I he sent me a copy of his
testimony so I could see it and I went
oh I think you sent in a typo so he prob
probably like me has a sticky key
somewhere it doesn't actually type when
he hits it anyway he brought up two
points that I found pretty pretty
Germain is that we have in um law let
see if I can find it now here is
[Music]
um H uh let's see RSA 467 in its
entirity alludes to and acknowledges the
fact that liability belongs to the
owners of trespassing lives act so for
for for instance if the neighbor's free
range chickens are in your dog pen and
your dog decides to have chicken for
dinner it's not your dog's fault um and
I'm so somewhere in his testimony he
also states that there is a um a a law
that that has um information on how dogs
will stand their ground on their
territory that they will defend their
territory from either stray animals or
people um I I believe our current law is
sufficient and that the problem may be
that it is not being enforced
the new addition strictly states that no
matter what dog bites twice it's
dead um are current law states that if
your dog has bitten people or animals or
whatever you um the court shall decide
for the disposition of the
animal if a man comes on your property
and is tempts to take a kit and you can
pick goat or child as you please um and
your dog bites the Hat heck out of that
guy is your dog a vicious dog I mean
there's there's so many different
reasons if your livestock Guardian dog
um takes out a dog that's trying to eat
the
Sheep is your dog a vicious dog or is it
doing his job our current law takes all
of that into consideration that there
are situations where dogs are doing
their job when they bite um there's
other situations of course where a dog
is out of control control it is not
under the control of its owner it is not
on its own property and that's where
current law comes into place it says a
judge should make a determination on
what should happen to that dog you know
some people may be willing to put their
dog in a 6x10 covered pen that it can't
escape from and keep their dog that way
to keep the public safe you don't know a
judge could take something like that
into
consideration um I think strictly
mandating that a dog dies simply for
having bitten some somebody twice um I
think the police would have a hard time
with that if their police dogs were put
down for that um I think puppy owners
would have a hard time with that those
people who are raising puppies of a
breed that is a mouthy bitey kind of dog
that you've got to work with and I'm
think some of you may be able to think
of those um that would that would be
terrible to say okay your puppy has to
die because it's bitten two kids um you
know and some somebody asked I don't
remember representative bisy asked about
rehabilitating a dog and the answer is
from what I can
see and what I have
handled if you have a dog that does not
have any bite inhibition that is it does
not control the strength of its bite
when it uses its
mouth you may be able to gain control of
that dog's Behavior by putting it under
your strict control but you probably
probably not ever going to stop that
situation where the dog is going to use
a full bite if it determines it's going
to bite um this is something you teach
baby puppies that oh humans are delicate
you you can't put teeth on us you know
and you we we'll we'll really be upset
and hurt um and adult dogs teach puppies
this too they whack them around if they
bite them too hard and they they they
give them a hard time so puppies learn
to control their mouth a puppy that is
raised and does not learn that when they
get to be an adult they're going to use
their full bite um so I think if you if
you ever watch the dog wh for program
you'll see that he is not um teaching
the dogs not to bite he's teaching the
owners how to control the dogs which is
a very different thing so anyway that
that's my point on this I think our
current law is perfectly fine and allows
for judicial discretion and um you know
the fact that this did not occur for the
person up north that the um that it
never made it to court um I I think that
it's an Enforcement issue not a law is
not right issue so yapped on along
enough if you got any questions happy to
answer them thank you appreciate it and
uh thank you for uh bringing forth the
comments for uh Mr finy who can't be
here um I do want to comment that you
know I'm looking through um RSA 467 in
its entire
and it does talk about um the owners of
bulls and stallions and Rams and wild
Wars and uh the liability
um and yes in in its entirety and what
it this RSA speaks of it is true that it
alludes to and acknowledges the fact
that the liability does belong to the
owners of the trespassing livestock so
if you have a dog that is trespassing on
your property and running around and
biting your kids um that's a problem and
that is something that law enforcement y
needs to be told about yeah so I would
take I would take a wild guess and say
that that dog that up north that was
causing is causing such issues has that
um expanded view of what its territory
is uh just just because it's the dog
suit doesn't mean it's the right one but
I think that that sounded like what was
going on to me from what I heard thank
you any questions representative Murray
I actually don't have a question for the
the speaker I had a just a question
about testimony from the previous
sorry if you're done with me I'll let
her have the chair representative Duty
oh
darn uh Miss Holmes do do you know you
know what you mention we hear often one
of non- enforcement or you know LAX
enforcement uh do you know of any
training programs for law enforcement on
our animal control laws or is that
something that we should be considering
is it I'm not sure is it part of like
the um training program at nhti you know
for La en think that there was a
training program or a partial one um um
I think the the person that might be
able to answer that is commissioner
Jasper about from from the Department of
AG I think that might have been one of
the places that and I think um one of
the Humane Societies maybe had training
programs for handling the laws but I you
know it wouldn't have been mandatory it
would have been you know voluntary um I
I think the police just like many others
have a lot on their plate and what they
know um
and it always behooves like an owner to
you know if your dog is attacked it
behooves you to know what the law is
about getting recourse for it or the
very least finding a lawyer who can do
that for
you I'm sorry I hope that makes
sense any not and um good Stacy Stacy
Miss oer I'm sorry thank you um thank
you madam chair I I I just was curious
did you submit um electronic testimony I
couldn't find electronic testimony on
the things that you stated or do you
have I submitted written written what I
submitted one written testimony with a
paragraph on each of the bills um this
afternoon but it didn't go in
electronically because I didn't get it
approved till late yesterday and then
got up early this morning to be here so
so that one document applies to all of
the bills correct there it's uh
segmented I don't know did you get a
written copy I have extras I think I did
and I just put it with the sure other so
yeah thank you thank you was that all
okay and I'm out of pink cards uh is
there anybody else who wishes to speak
bill Mr aronberg yeah uh Kurt aronberg
with the Humane Society of the United
States I did sign in as opposed to the
bill I think it's totally
unnecessary um I did want
to help out with the question of
training of Animal Control Officers
there is a one week training every
summer at UNH and
Durham as a graduate of that I should
know who puts it on and uh how you get
but I'll get you that
information um in terms of the police
academy offering it that's a good
question I'm not sure it happens now
there's some
so there is so again uh members of this
committee should be aware you know there
there are holes in the system and we
should look at how we can fix them so I
appreciate those
questions thank you appreciate it and
just if you have a pink card we'd
appreciate it
too thank you any other persons
interested in weighing in on this bill
today seeing none i' I'd like the blue
sheet thank you representative Duty
and um let me just quick
online appreciate it we have three
people on the blue sheet opposed to this
bill
and
yeah
this3 and online in the portal we have
21 opposed and two that
bill
okay
okay and I'm going to close out the
hearing for HB
1173 um we have until 2 o'clock uh for
the hearing for 1501 so we're going to
take a
you
sec
I'm going to get started with our
h501 so I am going to ask our uh sponsor
Bill sponsor uh representative Hull to
committee good afternoon and welcome to
environment and Agriculture and to dog
day
days good afternoon members of the
committee representative hle serving the
towns of dun Barton hooks at Allenstown
in
Epsom I think this is my 10th year at
the state house and I've never been
before this committee so this is a first
um what started as a simple request grew
into a multi-page
document I wish our Farms did as well as
OS did in drafting a very long document
we would be have plentiful fruit and
other Harvest this was simply a request
to repeal the requirement to pay $6 or
$7 every
year um the email to them said let's get
rid of the dog
tax every year every dog owner in the
state has to pay a fee to keep their pet
we don't do this for other animals we do
this effectively for dogs only I
understand the need for rabies
vaccinations I get that that was part of
the repeal that's not what I'm asking
for I'm asking to get rid of the annual
fee dogs can be licensed once but
there's no need to continue to do this
the pet owners and the veterinarians can
take care of the ensuring that the the
vaccinations are happening there's no
need to go print stamp email bills
around
Etc every year to Chase down6 or
seven a better requirement would be to
require these to be licensed once that
license is good for the life of the dog
and let the dog owner and the
veterinarian take care of the annual
shots that are necessary instead of
going through the trouble to have this
fee come every
April um secondly I'm not sure how this
happened but outside agencies are the
one sending in the information to
collect these fees now this isn't coming
directly from my town clerk um the town
clerks are working with other outside
groups to do the billing for this in
violation of current law because this
information should not be transmitted to
anybody else I don't care the people
know that I own a dog I've got pictures
of my dog it's on Facebook it's on
Twitter but our law says this
information should not be available to
other people um so there's clearly an
issue there as well of personal privacy
so what started is a simple request to
eliminate the six or I guess now $7 fee
every year turned into a multi-page
document I would ask that the document
that was turned in not be this was that
whole OS Rush at the end of the filing
period where things were not getting
done in time that we look at the bill
simply to request to eliminate the
requirement to re license a dog every
year thank
committee okay good representative
Howard thank you madam chair um do the
fees that that are collected for dog
registration um fund anything dog
related in the towns or the for the
state they do fund things within the
state
absolutely that's a benefit to all the
citizens in the state not just the dog
owners right this should be funded out
of the general fund I sit on on the
finance committee a much better
appropriation would it be to make sure
those activities are funded by the
general population and not just those
dogs so
if you your suggestion is that we
license the dog first you know one time
one time and then after that um they're
sort of on the honor System whether or
not they're going to vaccinate their dog
or not well the vet would presumably be
very interested in the health of the dog
the dog owner would be very interested
in the health of the dog everybody knows
that if a dog gets rabies you're putting
the dog down so there's lots of reasons
especially for dogs that spend any time
in the woods why you would go
proactively get this done but I'm not
sure that requires government oversight
in all of this I think this is something
that could easily be managed between the
veterinarian and the individual pet
owner that's okay that's representative
Murray question thank you madam chair um
I'm curious to know whether or not you
did mention some Statewide efforts for
public benefit programs um but what
about local um vaccine clinics or
efforts like that part of the fee going
to local efforts as well I I had one
person contact me and did some research
where these fees were going I did not
look at all of that there might be
people in the audience who have a better
understanding of how we divvy up this
$7 I think the point
is why are we taxing one pet
I like my dog Liberty's a great dog
great pet for the kids but this is not
something I can understand the payment
for getting the little stamp on the
whatever the little tag on the front
putting it on their collar if they ever
get away all of that makes sense dogs
tend to roam more than cats for instance
but for instance I've seen cats that
belong right no collar no nothing are
out walking around between neighborhoods
why aren't we doing the same for cats
now local we do allow local fness IP
alties to do this by requiring that they
have a tag and the tag be on them that
helps us find the owner I'm okay with
that that's not the problem the problem
is we continue to pay this every year
and it's dis it's a fixed fee so it's
disproportionate in terms of the cost to
the lower inome
families I think we can do a single
registration once and then leave the
responsibility for the vaccination
between the owners and their
veterinarians representative H Haskins
thank you madam chair thank you
representative for taking my questions I
have two I notice um that the animal
population control program would be
eliminated according to uh the
department of well as I said the the
request in what came out of legislative
services are completely out of sync
starting on page five line 18 following
repeals an enormous number of stuff I
was simply asking to repeal the
requirement to have the license
annually but yet this is the bill that's
before us I I hear that and if you need
me to help draft an amendment that gets
rid of the annual requirement I can go
to LLS they were scrambling at the end
of the filing period to get all of this
in by a deadline and I don't know how
this came to be I agree I signed off
because I had the option of signing off
or killing the bill and I signed it off
as is if you would like me to get an
amendment that simply eliminates the
requirement to continue to re license
your dog in subsequent years I can get
that drafted for you followup if I may
followup yep um secondly I'm concerned
that we're hearing testimony about dogs
out of control and um people and animals
being bitten and I wonder if you think
that human behavior being what it is
that relying on owners to do the right
thing and get their vaccinations and all
the rest is going to help the problem
that we've been listening to here
today so I wasn't I apologize I was not
here to hear all of the prior testimony
relative to dog biting and whatever um
most of the pet owners I know are very
responsible pet owner so I I don't
necessarily see that issue um I'm not
saying it does doesn't exist but from
where I stand um the groups of people
that I hang out with tend to be very
responsible adults and they take care of
their pets and so part of this the issue
might be real I'm not saying it isn't I
don't know how big it is so I can't
speak to that thank you repres Bixby are
you aware that the uh amount of money
from the dog license that goes to the
municipality is there as insurance
against Damage Done by dogs that are
running loose uh if you say so I believe
that could be the case thank you
representative
Howard I I'm sorry I forgot what I was
gonna ask I apologize problem all right
well we'll go to representative Duty and
then come back to you okay uh thank you
madam chair so if we pass this bill um
where uh so we do away with the dog
license where is there in the bill what
the charge would be um for a one-time
license and and how would that be done I
would leave the charge at the $7 for the
initial
license and for the life of the dog for
the life of the dog that means that we
have to come up with the other money
that is then was was generated in Prior
years with the annual license via
something through the state budget
followup followup okay uh are are you
aware that several years ago we had a
bill um to raise the dog license fee
from $5 to
$5.50 a year uh and that was going to
fund an animal abuse fund um for for
cities and towns that um look the other
way on animal abuse because they
couldn't afford to take care of the
animals and that was voted down uh one
penny a week less than a penny a week uh
because as we all know death are taxes
so I don't understand if the legislature
didn't want to fund one penny a week how
we're going to get I don't know a half a
million dollars out of the general fund
so so I may not have been in at that
point but there is a difference between
demanding that the dog owners pay 50
cents more and funding the necessary
item right I think you're conflicting G
the generation of Revenue and how and
where it's spent there's lots of ways
that we can tax the citizen
the dog owners tend to be a little bit
upset about continuing to have the dogs
be taxed so that 50 c increase was real
it was a 10% increase and that's
probably why it was voted down there's
no reason why in our six plus billion
doll annual budget we can't find the
$500,000 or whatever the final number is
to fund some of these things it does
benefit every citizen across the state
I don't think the dog owner should be
burden representive Howard apologies for
that little glitch um I I I don't have a
dog and I haven't registered a dog in a
long time so I I might be off a little
bit on this but is the the fact that the
dog got the rabies shot attached to
their record and if they um to their
registration so when you have when we do
it annually is it do we get the shot and
then we go register the dog yeah you get
the shot you register the dog the that
latest stamped collar shows that you've
T you've gone to the trouble to go to
your vet get your vet record sent to
your clerk have your clerk issue a tag
and then put the tag on that's what that
shows evidence of follow
up followup so um is there a way if we
were to register the dog once is there a
way to attach the rabies Rec records to
that one registration so that so that if
someone were to find your dog and um and
look him up or somehow would know that
he was um that he was up to date on his
vaccinations so I don't believe those
records are online right now they might
be um I don't believe you can go look up
a dog ID and figure out whether it's
vaccinated or not I think this
ultimately comes down to contacting the
owner and or the Town Clerk and or the
vet that's tied to that record I don't
believe there's any reason we couldn't
have the dog tag that has a number and
that information be available that says
this dog's name is X or her name is X
and that that information ties to a vet
that was at the time of registration
contact this vet now that vet may not be
the current vet I get it but at the time
that the dog was registered they Ed the
H hooks at veterinarian clinic and from
there that person can say I know who the
owner is we'll contact them there's a
bunch of ways to look up that
information I don't know that this
requires the fee to be to every every
year representative Murray thank you
madam chair um are there circumstances
in which a perhaps maybe a law
enforcement officer or um somebody else
would come to the town hall and ask for
proof of registration and vaccine um in
the event of there being an issue and
some of so stop there and then I have a
followup so I believe this information
is not to be shared is my understanding
I believe a police officer doing their
line of duty might need to get access to
that information as well um if they
found a dog for instance they may have
called The Town Clerk and say I have dog
that has license whatever 1 two-
367 um can you tell me who the owner is
so I can get the dog
returned
followup and there is there not another
circumstance in which maybe the dog has
bitten somebody and they are trying to
discern whether or not the animal has is
up to date or has been vaccinated AB
absolutely and if there's a tag on the
dog we can trace down back to the owner
Andor to the to the
veterinarian
um and find out whether that record is
accurate there's no reason we have to
force the owners to continue to get
these tags and put the tag on the dogs
compliance any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you
representative hall for presenting this
bill and I would call Stacy
speak good
afternoon thank you chair Aon members of
the committee Stacy oer with the
American Kennel Club and um wanted to
just go on record and say that AKC is a
believes it's important that responsible
ownership tools be preserved such as dog
licenses and we don't support repealing
the requirement that dogs be registered
annually um in addition to the funding
questions that have been proposed you
know the function of the dog license
includes um following for instance a
change of ownership so by virtue of
having to
annually register in town There's a um
insurance so to speak that the dog is on
record with the town or if a dog is
deceased then you would know okay this
dog is no longer in town or where it
resides in the event there's a fire and
fire department's respond how many dogs
are in the in the house there's there's
a desire to have that accurate count um
and as I was listening to testimony uh
from the sponsor with regard to whether
or not there's a need after your first
registration um in the event you had
let's say a serious injury from a dog
attack or maybe a dog that bit and for
some reason wasn't up to date on its
rabies for instance um my experience
with some of these horrible incidences
are that owners are not necessarily
forthcoming in that type of a scenario
to say yes I am the owner uh there was
an attack of a dog in Maine for instance
and that owner took off of from the site
uh rather than take responsibility for
their dog and for the situation so I do
think there is value in having an annual
dog license and ensuring that it's
accurate and up to date for the town um
in addition to you know a Veterinary
practice not being open or available and
the ability to ensure that the rabies
vaccine which typically expires every
three years and you have to renew it is
just part of responsible dog ownership
and a valuable tool so we support um
keeping it in
place thank you represent viby so uh we
just heard a bill um this morning about
vicious dog attacks uh does the
licensing requirement uh help in uh um
preventing uh bringing um those who are
responsible for vicious dogs to just to
Justice to make sure that they uh appr
appropriately restrain their dogs in the
future and uh are responsible for the
dogs ownership well I just think the dog
license because it's current is a uh
confirmation of who the current owner is
and that's a valuable uh piece of
information in the event of yes an
attack like that or if there was a
vicious dog that um had been labeled
that way you would certainly want to
know who the owner was and have that
accurate record um and to be certain it
hadn't been you know transferred to
somebody else for
instance okay thank you representative
Murray thank you madam chair would you
um also say that there's a public health
benefit to the fee um to ensuring um
that there's an opportunity for um the
public to receive uh local vaccine
clinics if there are any and other
services around um the health and
well-being of
animals yeah I know I know that um dog
license fees have been typically used
for um can be used for animal control uh
training they can be used for spay
neuter programs I think uh New Hampshire
dogs who will be testifying after me on
the bill probably provide you with the
details relative to how that money is
used from a public safety standpoint
here in New
Hampshire any other
questions seeing none thank you for your
Olsen
hi put your microphone on just press
button there you go hello yep okay
thanks
um aside from finding it generally
objectionable that I should need a
license to have a dog or get taxed to
have a dog uh I think practically
speaking this is
counterproductive um the the only reason
that my town knows that I have a dog is
because I brought my dog in to get a RAB
shot that's the point at which they
gather that information and give it to
the town um if I value my privacy and or
don't want to pay the fee or don't want
to have to go in and deal with the town
on this matter the only way I can avoid
that is to not get the rabies shot this
is an incentive to not get it it I don't
see how this would in any way encourage
people to get it uh all they would end
up doing is paying more tax um as far as
keeping track of people track of owner
track of whether or not the dog has
rabies that's what the little tags on
the dog do um if you are responsible
enough to get a shot and put a tag and
put your phone number in contact
information on your animal people are
going to be able to find you and know
that it got a shot and know when and by
what doctor um if you're not responsible
to do that and you don't put a tag on
nobody's going to know that information
whether you paid a license fee or not
because they're not going to know whose
dog it is to look up that license um so
this entire thing seems kind of
counterproductive um I would also
question how worthwhile Gathering funds
in this manner is you're Gathering you
know what six or seven dollars uh you
have the staff of the hospital going and
recording this information relaying it
to the town the town is recording it
then the town sending me out a letter um
telling me that I have to come in and
write a check for this $6 you know how
many people's time effort and postage is
wasted collecting
$7 uh this just seems like a really
ineffective way to I mean couldn't uh
couldn't some other tax just be $7
higher um that's all
thanks question I just have
clarification oh yeah um thank you I'm
also acting as clerk today so if you uh
would mind are you here representing
yourself or or another organization or
just myself okay thank you
representative du
Duty thank you thank you for taking your
right question so if $7 and I agree you
know it's a little bit of money uh what
if we did an average age of a dog let's
say 13 years and we multiplied that by
seven and so it was a one-time fee of
let me do it in my head what's that $91
a year uh would that be preferable to
you I I would object to any kind of a
dog license or fee I don't really think
it's the town's business whether or not
I have a dog um and as far as like
tracking for liability or anything I
people are already liable and and held
responsible for what their pets
do so if can I have one followup sure so
so I assume you're also against driver's
licenses because that involves a fee and
you're also against uh registra auto
registration fees because that involves
I mean you know auto registration is
annual I think a license is every five
years so you would be against that
also I don't see what that has those are
completely different things you're
actually interacting with other people
on the road and there's a whole bunch of
other stuff that goes into driver's
licenses and we use them for all kinds
of other things
um you know you could make all kinds of
arguments about that but I don't see how
they're really relevant to this this
specific license doesn't seem to
um okay so um so then you would be fine
with your dog not having any kind of tag
and if it got loose and then bit
somebody then there would be no way for
Animal Control who caught your dog to
trace the dog back to you no of course
not my dog has tags and had tags long
before the town knew I had a dog and
assessed me a fee for it uh my dog has
my address my phone number as well as
the rabies tags and show when and where
that that rabies vaccine was given um I
absolutely want people to know that it's
my dog and return it to me and let me
know what's going on with it if anything
should happen or if she got away um and
I think I would expect that to be nearly
Universal amongst people who own dogs um
I I don't think this is a problem and I
I don't know of this being a problem in
places where they don't have dog
licenses so you're you're assuming that
everybody is going to follow the same
protocol that you do if if they didn't
have to get a rabies vaccine and get
tags um um what if they decided they
didn't want to put any tags on their dog
and the dog gets out and bites somebody
there's no way to trace the animal back
to the owner and find out whether or not
the dog was vaccinated or who owns it or
whatever uh yes but that's true whether
or not there's a fee in fact the the fee
we want all the dogs to get their Raby
shots I do I want my dog to have a Raby
shot I want the other dogs to have a
Raby shot and I want people to know that
and see it on the tag uh but by
attaching a fee and an extra process to
it and you know you have the personal
information and privacy issue by adding
all of this extra stuff you're
disincentivizing people from doing that
um you know am I more or less likely to
want to go in and get the rabies shot if
I know I'm going to be harassed by the
town and charged a fee for doing it how
how would that encourage me to get the
rabies shot how is it going to encourage
other dog owners to get the Raby shot
obviously I'm going to get it anyway
because it's an important thing to do um
but I don't think it seems to me that
the the uh the stated intention of this
is is not really aligned with actually
achieving that goal it seems like it's
doing the opposite to me okay any other
questions from the
committee see none thank you for coming
in speaking with us this
Holmes
good afternoon again for the record my
name is Nancy Holmes I'm up here today
from New Boston I want to talk about
what a good thing it is to have dogs
licensed in this state
um our dog licensing program is
important beyond the recovery of lost or
stray pets which is also
important a little closer to me okay I
thought you might be tired of
me um because we license our dogs New
Hampshire is one of the few states that
has vastly reduced the production of
unexpected unwanted and unplanned
litters by portions of the fee funding
our spay neuter fund our dog linging
also helps fund the Diagnostics lab and
within our towns money uh money from um
the tag goes into our town coffers to
help pay for animal control issues um
and I believe somebody mentioned that it
goes into um helping handle the the cost
of a of a dog causing
damages
um so it would actually H because
um getting a license is proof of current
rabies vaccine our pets and their owners
are safer I Want You cast your minds
back to when this bill happened that the
rabies
vaccine and dog licensing were tied
together the reason this was done is
because people were not vaccinating
their pets against rabies and it was
determined that this was an extremely
important thing to have done because we
do have rabies in New Hampshire so that
there was there was a reason behind that
whole connection um and it's now I think
it's electronic now that the information
goes from the vet to most of the towns
and they just have it online to handle
to when you come in to license your pet
um that long list of rsas that would be
cancelled that's the list of unintended
consequences you know everybody's wentw
why is this long list of ours because
that's what would H that's what would no
longer be needed or would no longer be
able to happen if you take away the dog
licensing fee um trying think there
anything else that I had here for you oh
if anybody's town has a dog tag that
actually lasts for an entire year on
their dog I am so jealous I can't
imagine one that or the cost one that
would actually last for the lifetime of
a dog I haven't had it I mean I bought a
absolute dog proof guarantee to keep the
um tag on the dog's collar from a dog
supply catalog and both my dogs remove
them from their collars within about a
half an hour of having the tags attached
so I'm jealous if somebody's got tags
that actually stay on that that that's
interesting um but you know I I think
that we're that the law as it stands
particularly with the rise in people who
are against vaccinations of any type um
I think the law as it stands really
protects our pets and our people um from
the dangers of rabies and that the yeah
the dog owners shoulder the burden of
things like the spay neuter fund and the
Diagnostics left that all animals
benefit from but there absolutely
nothing preventing towns except the
outcry um from having the same thing
done for cats um but I think right now
with just the dog's contributions we're
doing an awful lot of good in this state
and I think it would be a shame to end
that just because somebody finds it too
difficult to write a small check to
their town to get a license for their
dog be happy to answer any questions any
questions from the
committee seeing none thank you and I
call Angela
dogs one I I seriously hope that the
stuff I submitted through the portal
actually gets to
you I'm looking at it now oh good like
paper all right good afternoon Angela
Ferrari dog owners of the Granite State
um here to talk a little bit about
repealing the requirement to register
dogs annually and dive into a little bit
of the facts behind some of the funds
that we have um dog owners does oppose
this bill but the animal population
control fund or program I should say um
contributes extensively to as Nancy
mentioned the prevention of having one
stray animals due to unwanted litters
and things like that
um and that fund has done such a great
job over the years that we've actually
had to start bringing in animals from
other states to provide um the or to
support the demands of what people want
for dogs and cats in our state also we
recently had a bill which you probably
remember that transferred some of the
money from the uh animal population
control program to our New Hampshire
veterinary diagnostic laboratory fund um
because we did have a a surplus in there
due to how well that bill has or that
program has done and th both of those
are funded by the licenses that are
received annually from dog licenses um
in general it's a little over a million
dollars that comes in annually to the
state of New Hampshire from those fees
from the licenses and gets dispersed
into the various funds including what
the uh municipalities get as small
portion of that fee for their
administrative duties and then
additionally any money that would go
into their general fund the New
Hampshire veterinary diagnostic
laboratory uh would lose around
$95,000 of that annually um and that's a
really important program that we have um
currently that a diagnostic laboratory
is studying the respiratory illness that
you've likely heard about in New
Hampshire that's been affecting a lot of
dogs not just in New Hampshire out of
the state as well but New Hampshire um
and that lab is one of the places that
is collecting samples from around the
country um to try to determine what the
cause of that illness is and what we can
do to resolve that um so the those are
just a few of the impacts that removing
this license fee could have knowing that
we would still get the license fee for
you know the first year of the dog we
know we would see a significant drop in
the funds available for these different
programs um as you've heard you know in
regards to rabies itself huge public
safety concerns if there isn't that
tracking mechanism to ensure people are
getting the dogs their Raby vaccines um
in years past and even coming up next
we're going to be talking about how do
we reduce educe what is required to get
a rabies vaccine or allowing exemptions
on rabies vaccines we've heard bills
about not getting rabies vaccines with
the ability to tighter for rabies which
is something we can do for other
diseases but isn't approved yet in the
United States for rabies so whether you
know we want to allow citizens to say
I'm going to do it I promise we know
that there's already a drive towards how
can we reduce ruce the amount of rabies
vaccines we're putting into our dogs so
if we are taking away the annual process
that's ensuring that those vaccines are
happening we are going to be opening up
the ability for people to avoid those
vaccines even more so than what we're
seeing them try to do today now I
understand that a lot of it has to do
with how do we save the individual dog
owner some money $7 a year maybe you
have a couple dogs it starts to add up
am I excited to pay my dogs licensing
bills every year no um but I still do it
I know it's going to my town which I
appreciate the town that I live in and
what they do for us that money isn't
going to just disappear it's going to
get repurposed or not repurposed but
you're going to receive that bill in
another form if we're moving it from the
municipality over to the veterinarian
well now they have to start tracking
which dogs have their licenses uh or had
their rabies vaccines when they're due
they have to start making communication
to the people and make sure that the
dogs are receiving the vaccines and
doing that tracking mechanism that the
towns are currently doing guarantee
we're going to see an increase in the
cost of that rabies vaccine through your
veterinarian so do we want to take it
away from the town so it feels like
you're not spending $7 transfer it to
the
veterinarian um where you're still going
to to get that fee in one way or
another and then people can just
transfer vets as a means to avoid that
you can ignore your vet but can you
ignore your town clerk who's going to
send the Animal control officer to your
house if you have not let them know that
your dog died or paid your license fee
with proof of rabies vaccine I usually
find out from my town that my dog's
rabies vaccine is coming up on its
expiration date and I say oh okay Raley
is going to need his rabes vaccine this
year I'm going to get him into the Vet
so that when I license him I can provide
that to them and I don't have to have
them chase me down for it um so those
are a few of the things um I'm trying to
think if there was anything else oh one
of the other things going back to public
safety concerns if somebody does get bit
by a dog and it can't be proven that
that dog has had its rabies vaccine it
can cost upwards of $4,000 per person
just to go through the medical treatment
um to ensure that they aren't going to
get rabies from a dog who may or may not
have had its vaccine um so there's
definitely extending costs that could
come of this um and I think that pretty
much covers everything that I had but I
would be up for any questions thank you
yeah so um my question is do you you see
that
um instead of some people call this a
dog
tax do you consider it more of a user
fee I mean in that in so far as if if
you weren't paying your $7 a year for
your
dog that some of these
other um the Diagnostic lab and some of
the other things that are funded by the
dog license in fee would then have to be
borne by um the general fund the rest of
the taxpayers in the in the state so
would you consider this to be more of a
user fee since you have a dog and you
have interest in um the the operation of
the lab and and that kind of thing going
on in the state yeah I could definitely
see it as more of a a user fee also as
soon as we start asking all of the dog o
non dog owners to approve monies coming
from the general fund to go into things
that aren't important to them such as
the animal population control or the
Diagnostic lab we may start receiving
push back and therefore the general fund
may not be able to fund those programs
any longer um so if that's going to be
something that is part of having a dog I
think it would be only fair thank you uh
any other questions
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony today uh is there anyone else
I have no more ping cards is there
anyone else who's interested in speaking
for or against the spill seeing none
thank you for getting the blue sheet
representative Duty and the online
portal where people have been submitting
their testimony we have two people in
support of hp1501 and 22 opposed
with one
neutral and then on our blue sheet we
have uh three people opposed to
h501 and with that I'm going to close
out the hearing and
hp1501 and I will open up the hearing
for HB
1556 which is relative to exemptions
from the rabies vaccine and here to
introduce that bill to us is
representative Ammon welcome to
environment and agriculture thank you so
much thank you madam chair it's good to
be in front of your
committee um and hello to the committee
members uh for the record my name is uh
Keith Ammon I represent New Boston mon
Vernon and lineboro and it's District 42
in Hillsboro
County and I'm here to introduce House
Bill
1556 um it is rabies related but it's a
lot different than the previous bill I
think that you heard and I I'll just set
up uh my understanding of this um this
bill is a constituent
request uh and that constituent is here
and we'll we'll present testimony so um
we'll keep that in mind uh this section
of law was uh tweaked I think last year
and so this would be an additional tweak
um this has to do with dogs that are
sick
and in a health condition
where uh vaccination may may compromise
their health condition further so that's
the the narrow area that we're focused
on so these are old dogs or dogs with
immune uh compromis conditions uh who H
who get an exemption from the rabies
shot so they they are Exempted from it
but current statute requires the OWN to
treat the dog as if it has rabies so
these old and sickly dogs have to walk
around with a muzzle when whenever they
go outside uh that's really the the key
um area that we would like to to tweak I
believe um so there's some uh there's
some misunderstanding I think about how
this bill would affect uh wildlife and
agriculture that it's a it's it's
narrowly focused to dogs that are sickly
and they already have an exemption from
the rabies vaccine they would still have
to be leashed and under the physical
Direct Control of the owner but they
would be exempt from having to wear a
muzzle uh when they're outside on a hot
July August day um for example um it
does strict some things about having the
exemptions signed by the American
College of Veterinary and Internal
Medicine a diplomate from that and also
the state
veterinarian um and we can we can talk
about you know whether that's uh the
best approach or not so I'll leave this
bill to the committee in the good hands
of the committee and I'd be happy to
work with you if you find any uh things
that need to be tweaked um and I will
point out is it is a bipartisan Bill uh
representative buroughs and myself are
both
sponsors all right without take any
questions okay so what I'm seeing is
then uh we would be striking out the
recommendation signed by the American
College of Veterinary Internal Medicine
Diplomat diplomate and the state
veterinarian and we would also
say that
um the Exempted animal shall be
maintained in strict rabies isolation
under conditions that are at the
discretion of the local rabies control
Authority until such time as medical
condition has been resolved and the
animal can be immunized so that's
stricken as well as when the animal's
Outdoors it shall be
muzzled uh in a manner approved by the
local rabies control Authority so those
three parts are stricken from um the
rabies vaccination
exemption so I'm just making that clear
that's a correct reading of the the bill
okay good enough thanks yeah and just
just to reiterate the these dogs don't
have rabies and they have an exemption
from the vaccine but they're being
treated as if they have rabies right
that's kind of the right because
normally when uh say a dog has um
horrible reaction to rabies vaccine um
and the owner doesn't want to put their
dog through uh getting those kinds of
reactions they can apply for an
exemption for the
animal but then they haven't had the
rabies vaccine so they are then um you
know it's possible that they could be
carrying
rabies
um representative Murray thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question um I appreciate you being
before the committee um are you aware of
there being a way to determine whether
or not aside from physical appearance
and symptoms that may outwardly present
themselves in an animal's disposition uh
if they were to contract rabies are you
aware of another way of determining that
while the animal is still living I I'm
not an expert so I I don't know I'd
imagine that there probably are tests
the animal animal doesn't go outside on
its own so it's it's always under the uh
under the uh control of the owner so
there is oversight um not not to be glit
but I could have rabes right like uh you
know it's a it's a thing that we can all
get um and we just have to keep track of
our contact with Wildlife or other
things that you know lead to that Vector
of disease so represent Murray um thank
you for the followup I guess so my
question is then um your request is to
strike the the muzzle requirements and
if an animal is out and about in the
public so not just in the home so my
question is if an animal were to come in
contact um who was unvaccinated and
potentially had you know come into
contact with another animal or you know
been exposed to rabies in some other way
is there a concern that there might
possibly be an interaction and where
rabies could be trans it's a very remote
possibility from just the way that I you
know imag imagine how things would go um
I am a dog owner I've had dogs that were
sickly and you know that that at the end
of their life we try to make them as
comfortable as possible
so thank you okay representative Duty
yes thank you madam chair I don't know
if you know the answer to this question
but uh you know last year we did do the
exemption for ant um dogs that have a
reaction so if we strike out uh some of
these Clauses here will that affect
those animals also um because a lot of
them are younger stronger animals but
they have a reaction so they wouldn't
have to be muzzled either uh because
that would be a concern would this Bill
affect um the requirements that we've
set for those animals so it would apply
to any uh dog that got that has this
exemption right and and just just to
reiterate the leash requirement is still
in there it's just the muzzle
requirement that would be removed for
for those
dos okay any
questions representative Bixby yeah so
um are you aware that um it was just
last year that we uh changed the law
from requiring the uh the signature of
the American College of veterinarian
inter and internal medicine diplomate
and the state veterinarian uh beyond the
first granting of the exemption so now
they those two signatures are only
needed when the exemption is first
granted any uh and that's something that
we we just put into into while last
year I know this so when I put the bill
in for drafting OS made me aware that it
was adjusted last year um and so we kind
of worked with that but I wasn't steeped
in it at the time so I I'll take your
word for it it was the only the first
exemption okay thank you thank you any
other questions seeing none thank you
representative an Ammon thank you uh
Stacy
Club good afternoon chair Aon members of
the committee Stacy oer with the
American Kennel Club and on House Bill
1556 um we do have concerns about the
Bill's attempt to loosen the
requirements for exemption from the
rabies vaccine and uh in particular to
eliminate the requirement that a muzzle
be used on an exempt dog when
Outdoors um if it was enacted it would
solely rely upon the exempt dog owner's
voluntary compliance with the remaining
requirement that the dog be on a leash
at all times to ensure Public Safety
and I cannot overstate the seriousness
of rabies which is a potentially fatal
zunic disease most often transmitted
through the bite of a rabbit
animal just uh Googling quick about
rabies in New Hampshire and the
incidents of that
um an article came up that last in
November two stray kittens in New
Hampshire tested positive for rabies and
the authorities were working to identify
people who may have been exposed to the
rabies after these two stray kittens in
North Conway tested positive for the
disease so a concerned citizen picked up
the first kitten with rabies took it to
the Area Humane Society New Hampshire
Department of Public Health and Human
Services uh two Veterinary practices
cared for the kitten before it started
exhibiting symptoms and uh two days
later it tested positive officials said
the people who had Direct contact with
the infected kitten might
require preventative treatment and we're
identified so the reason I bring this up
is as a dog owner for instance obviously
we all enjoy and appreciate that our
dogs need exercise and you want to be
able to go out and let them off leash
maybe in a wooded area or something of
that nature if a dog has not been
vaccinated for R for rabies the root of
transmission is a bite and there are
different types of muzzles available out
there um some of you might think of as
being a little bit constraining um if
let's say you're going to run with your
dog get them some exercise can they
breathe and perspire
adequately they do have something called
a basket muzzle which just sits on the
nose and it allows the dog to open its
mouth and pant and whatnot so I just
wanted to clarify that a muzzle doesn't
have to be something that's restrictive
um but it would in fact prevent a bite
um if you had a dog that's muzzled let's
say it had a bite history or something
of that nature inevitably as the dog
owner you would never let it off the
leash because it wouldn't be able to
protect itself if something attacked it
so uh in our estimation the highest
priority is the muzzle um being on a dog
that is has clearly not been um
vaccinated for rabies so I just wanted
to make those TP couple of examples for
you all and I'm happy to take any
questions that you might have any
questions from the committee
represent Bixby so um does it ever occur
that uh an owner has a dog on on its
leash and the dog manages to escape from
the owner anyway oh sure if you had a
big dog sure if they saw something and
wanted to take off after it they could
that's an excellent point uh
representative
Bixby any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you Miss
Holmes and I just want to say after that
I only have one more pink card so if
there's anyone else who wishes to speak
on this bill please um let me
know
well my name is Nancy Holmes I'm here
today from New Boston in opposition to
this
bill um as I live out in the country I
have perhaps a little more sensitive to
the um topic of rabies and animals than
some others might be I've given a lot of
thought about this about the animals
that can't be vaccinated for their own
safety against rabies and the
protections that keep these animals safe
while also keeping the public safe I
believe the rabies isolation uh method
and the muzzle rule should be kept in
place a muzzle even a soft rubber one
prevents bites and protects the public
that same muzzle also issues serves as a
warning to people to be cautious of
interactions and to speak to the owner
before approaching the
dog um I believe the verification of the
dog status is needing an exemption by
three person persons in the first year
of exemption is a necessary method to
avoid fraudulent exemption claims you
know your brother-in-law could sign an
exemption for you I don't think that
would work um there there really are
people out there who are so anti
vaccination that they would not
vaccinate the dog against rabies if they
could figure out a way to get out of it
legally so yes there are dogs that are
sick and should not have the vaccine
because it's not safe for them but I'm
not so sure about the people who try to
get around things we seem to have a lot
of that lately um I don't see any
advantage to the public as in changing
the law as it stands we tried really
hard last year to make it less honorous
by saying okay first time around you've
got to get everybody sign off that yeah
your dog really needs this um not only
does that prevent fraud but it also
gives you a shot at maybe some other vet
an internal medicine vet saying hey I
know what we can do about this um I just
don't see I think it's a a mild
inconvenience to an
owner and I think Public Safety warrants
that
effort be happy to answer any questions
okay any questions from the committee
Ferrari
all right good afternoon we're getting
close to wrapping up for the day yeah uh
Angela Ferrari dog owners of the Granite
State and we oppose this bill um a lot
of great things have been covered so
I'll just touch on a few things
um imuno compromised dogs they can still
get rabies so while we understand that
we need to be cautious about their
health in receiving vaccinations we do
need to take it very seriously that they
could contract the disease not only to
other animals but to people as well so
we do have public health risk um by
relaxing the laws regarding rabies
exemptions Animal Welfare concerns as
well um um removing the requirement for
strict isolation and muzzle use puts
Exempted animals at risk of Contracting
rabies continuing as I said before
jeopardizing the health of others the
topic of muzzles I think is really
interesting and I hadn't put a lot of
thought into it until I started hearing
the testimony today I wish I had brought
a video and if I remember maybe I will
send it to you all but my cousin who has
a dog who recently was neutered
um she needed to use a muzzle on him
because no matter what size cone or this
or that she put on the dog he could
still access the the Staples he was not
supposed to and utilizing treats and
everything he willingly will go over to
the muzzle when it is on the table and
try to put his face in it because he
knows that he gets treats um you know so
they can be introduced to them and
socialized to them in such a way that
that it really isn't something that's
going to be a negative impact to the dog
and there are a various array of types
of muzzles so that you can find one
that's comfortable not too bulky and is
going to serve your dog in the right way
um as you know I breed Dobermans and we
often refer to them as Dober goats and
that is because they will eat anything
that they can find from grass to leaves
to branches to anything and many people
need to utilize muzzles on their dogs
consistently while they're out in the
yard to prevent them from eating things
that they shouldn't which could then
result in a blockage um which is pretty
scary as well so there are a lot of dogs
utilizing muzzles for other reasons and
utilizing them um consistently on a
daily basis with no issues another thing
to mention in regards to muzzles is uh I
participate in corean ability trials
with my dogs that's when they chase a
bag that's on a line around a Big Field
um and you will often see dogs who are
wearing muzzles during that activity
because they may not work well with
other dogs and they are loose to protect
the other dogs they're utilizing a
muzzle in a very high endurance activity
um very successfully so just a few
examples that muzzles you know can be
comfortable can be used in a WI variety
of instances and with the benefits that
we get for dogs who don't need or aren't
able to get the vaccine um it shouldn't
be looked at as something that's
extremely negative um and then lastly I
just want to mention the reduction of
oversight in that initial exemption um
by cutting out the state
veterinarian and the American College of
Veterinary Internal Medicine um we think
that reduces the expert oversight that's
so important in making the decision on
if this animal truly is a candidate for
such a serious exemption it isn't
something as Nancy stated earlier that
should be done willy-nilly by anybody um
it really needs to be thought through
are there other avenues of getting this
vaccine into this dog that are safe a
lot of holistic vets have a plan in
place for if we have dog that is going
to be compromised by any sort of vaccine
but we understand the importance of
making sure they're protected we're
going to follow a set of um guidelines
before and after the vaccine is given so
it's important that all of these things
are considered before just saying you
know I don't like the rabus vaccine this
vet's willing to sign off and say I
don't need it and now I'm good to go
because I don't have to prove it to the
state vet or this other uh veterinarian
community community so with those few
things um we would oppose this bill and
I would be happy to answer any questions
uh representative Murray and then Bixby
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question I just want to make
sure I'm still correct in the assumption
that um to this date there is no cure
for rabies is that accurate I am not
aware of one no purum fixby yeah so um
when uh is there a period between the
time that an animal gets exposed to
rabies and the time that it starts to
show symptoms so that you could suspect
that it was
sick I do know that there's a period of
time when they will not be showing
symptoms so I think that's the more
critical piece is that they could be
exposed by getting a bite or they don't
even have to receive a bite they could
get the saliva from a rabbit animal into
a cut or you know into themselves some
how so you wouldn't even see a bite on
your dog uh to know that they may have
been exposed and then could
inadvertently be exposing them where
they could transmit it before they start
showing signs I do not recall the exact
incubation period before symptoms would
show okay represent Penza this might
have been covered before but has um do
we know the numbers of dogs that have
had rabies in the last I don't know
let's say five or 10 years in New
Hampshire did you have that Stacey no we
can look that up for you and and make
sure we follow up with that information
we can also get that from the state
veteran that's what I was going to say
sure would you be okay with the bill if
it just um if it didn't strike out in
regards with the muzzle and then but the
other two strikeouts were there so we
would still oppose uh not having the
state veterinarian in the American
College of Veterinary internal medicine
as part of that initial exemption
approval so we would like to see that
remain the piece that I would consider
and would want to take back to my
colleagues um after kind of thinking
through it more today would be the
strict rabies isolation and what that
means um so I would want to know a
little bit more about what
exactly that means but I think the
muzzle piece and the Vets is very
can I one more follow follow um yeah I I
think that the that Exempted animal is
really kind of um insane it's I don't
know who would monitor that and it just
seems a little um over the top so now if
a licensed
veterinarian um signs off on this
recommendation what's the process for
them to have to then jump a hoop to go
to the American College of Veterinary
Internal Medicine Diplomat and state
veterinarian it seems as if so are we
not trusting uh we not trusting our vets
to be able to if they put something in a
in a in a legal document that we trust
them with that that we have to then make
them jump through another hoop I don't I
don't understand that I think it's
because of the public safety concerns
that the state veterinarian is involved
in that
determination and because we do have a
WI variety of opinions across the
veterinary field and some who may be
more lenient in being anti- rabes and
not wanting to move forward with those
vaccinations in general could be
providing those exemptions when it maybe
truly isn't detrimental to the health of
the animal thank you representative
Marie thank you madam chair I I was just
going to comment on on and this is just
a point of clarification that um the
state veterinarian has the the oversight
over infectious disease and zoonotic
disease transfer around things like
rabies so I think that that is why that
inclusion is in
there any other questions for Miss
Ferrari seeing none thank you very much
thank you all very much and the last
Phelps good afternoon and welcome to
environment
agriculture put your microphone on there
there you go okay you're all set can you
all hear me thank you for having me here
today um I am in support of this bill
and um I will just tell you that unlike
maybe anybody else in the room I have
experience getting a medical exemption
on an animal in 2017 I had a dog that
was diagnosed with fatal cancer she was
10 years old that diagnosis
coincidentally occurred the same month
that she was supposed to get her booster
so the veterinarian
gave me the medical exemption Instead
This cancer um attacked her digestive
system so she was nauseous and having to
put a muzzle on her when sometimes I
know she just wants to go outside to get
some fresh air was a hardship for both
of us sadly she died within a month of
Her diagnosis so this didn't last very
long I now have a 14-year-old G ner who
has non-cancerous liver tumors some of
them were surgically removed in the
summer of 2022 the ones that could not
be removed are growing and he's on
medication to help his liver function
properly in the spring of
2023 he was up for his rabies
vaccination and he did receive it
because he was deemed not sick enough to
get the exemption a few days later he
was in the ER nearly dying of a liver
infection this is not considered an
allergic reaction to the rabus vaccine
but I believe his liver was not healthy
enough to handle the extra stress of a
vaccination at that time should I be
lucky enough to still have this dog when
he's 16 years old he will be up for
another rabies vaccine I doubt he would
survive it but I also would not look
forward to putting him in a muzzle for
the last days of his life dogs that are
getting these medical exemptions often
have digestive issues or need to be
rushed outside to relieve themselves and
taking the time to muzzle them is an
extra burden especially if the dogs are
vomiting on top of that I wonder that if
it's really necessary to treat these
dogs the same as if they have had an
exposure to rabies if one of these dogs
is exposed to rabies we already have
laws specifically RSA sections 436 105
and
43616 that would take into effect for
example one of these dogs could be
considered a past their vaccination the
veterinarian and the dog owner could
decide at that time to vaccinate them
and conine them to the house for 45 days
or opt for the stricter option which is
in section 1061 a at the owner's expense
the dog would be confined outside of
their home on top of that there is a
study out of the University of Wisconsin
that shows they say confirmed that
rabies vaccine May induce a duration of
immunity with well beyond three years in
dogs so they're they had 80% of dogs
tested in their study were still
protected against rabies six years after
a rabies vaccine had been administered
the dogs who are getting the rabies
exemption have followed the
protocol their whole life up until the
day they are deemed too Med too sick to
get this exemption and according to this
study they are highly likely to still be
protected against rabies even if they
have been exposed it seems seems like a
an unnecessary burden to muzzle these
dogs when they go outside especially if
you keep in the build strict isolation
these are not dogs that are going out in
public um they are just staying in their
owner's yards they and they're not going
to last long enough to worry
about exposure to rabies because they're
being let off leash in the woods and
being exposed to wild animals
um I'm happy to take so do you believe
that um there should be some provision
for dogs who have uh some
life-threatening illnesses like cancer
or uh some uh GI issues that um they
should be exempt from having to deal
with the rabies protocol well I I feel
like the research that went into
allowing the state of New Hampshire to
have a rabes exemption which I
completely appreciate
um that all of those decisions should be
made by veterinarians who are State
Certified and if we're not trusting our
veterinarians through our state
certification process then that needs to
be looked into but if the dog is sick
enough to get
Rab's
exemption that's a decision that the
veterinarian should make not the dog
owner if that answers your question
sure
any other questions from the
committee seeing none I want to thank
you for your testimony this afternoon
thank you very much and I would request
is there anybody else who wishes to
speak on this
bill seeing none uh request the blue
sheet
please
thank
you so on the blue sheet we have four
people uh three people who are uh
against this bill on the online portal
we have five people in support of this
bill and 21 opposed and one person who
is
neutral and with that I'm going to close
out the hearing for HB
1556 and and
um anything else from the committee this
afternoon um I did read the written
testimony somebody said that they had oh
that was Miss Phelps you could I only I
only have one that's fine it's just for
the
record okay I
want you're welcome to do that this is
just for thank you thank you everybody
for uh attending today and lending your
lending us your testimony and your
comments and I appreciate the work of
our committee this afternoon so thanks
and see you all next
week
tomorrow tomorrow well we'll see you
tomorrow the committee meets next
week oh the week after the week after
yes not next week next week is school
vacation week there is no committee
meetings next
week
yay
it's